This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. There's a scene in the 1986 movie Ferris Bueller's Day Off that has become iconic. It's a spot-on portrayal of what it feels like to be disengaged and disaffected. In the film, actor Ben Stein plays an economics teacher who is not about to win any teaching awards. He speaks in a deathly monotone. In 1930, the Republican-controlled House of Representatives, in an effort to alleviate the effects of the, anyone, anyone? The Great Depression passed the, anyone, anyone?
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. There's a scene in the 1986 movie Ferris Bueller's Day Off that has become iconic. It's a spot-on portrayal of what it feels like to be disengaged and disaffected. In the film, actor Ben Stein plays an economics teacher who is not about to win any teaching awards. He speaks in a deathly monotone. In 1930, the Republican-controlled House of Representatives, in an effort to alleviate the effects of the, anyone, anyone? The Great Depression passed the, anyone, anyone?|||This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. There's a scene in the 1986 movie Ferris Bueller's Day Off that has become iconic. It's a spot-on portrayal of what it feels like to be disengaged and disaffected. In the film, actor Ben Stein plays an economics teacher who is not about to win any teaching awards. He speaks in a deathly monotone. In 1930, the Republican-controlled House of Representatives, in an effort to alleviate the effects of the, anyone, anyone? The Great Depression passed the, anyone, anyone?
The tariff bill. The students in the classroom are suffering from a boredom that verges on the catatonic. On and on, the teacher goes, asking for responses, but barely expecting any. And indeed, no one ventures a word. Today, we have a similar debate over this. Anyone know what this is? Class. Anyone? Anyone? Anyone seen this before?
The tariff bill. The students in the classroom are suffering from a boredom that verges on the catatonic. On and on, the teacher goes, asking for responses, but barely expecting any. And indeed, no one ventures a word. Today, we have a similar debate over this. Anyone know what this is? Class. Anyone? Anyone? Anyone seen this before?|||The tariff bill. The students in the classroom are suffering from a boredom that verges on the catatonic. On and on, the teacher goes, asking for responses, but barely expecting any. And indeed, no one ventures a word. Today, we have a similar debate over this. Anyone know what this is? Class. Anyone? Anyone? Anyone seen this before?
The Laffer Curve. Anyone know what this says? There is no spark of interest or curiosity. The movie Goa can hardly blame Ferris for skipping out on school to spend a day of fun with his friends. For many of us, there is a reason this scene may be resonant. Our own time in school might have resembled this. Students currently enrolled.
The Laffer Curve. Anyone know what this says? There is no spark of interest or curiosity. The movie Goa can hardly blame Ferris for skipping out on school to spend a day of fun with his friends. For many of us, there is a reason this scene may be resonant. Our own time in school might have resembled this. Students currently enrolled.|||The Laffer Curve. Anyone know what this says? There is no spark of interest or curiosity. The movie Goa can hardly blame Ferris for skipping out on school to spend a day of fun with his friends. For many of us, there is a reason this scene may be resonant. Our own time in school might have resembled this. Students currently enrolled.
may experience a shiver of recognition. It's not just in educational settings. Have you ever attended a meeting where leaders of your organization drone on about some new initiative or corporate mumbo-jumbo? As your eyelids grow heavy with sleep, you fear your head is going to fall
may experience a shiver of recognition. It's not just in educational settings. Have you ever attended a meeting where leaders of your organization drone on about some new initiative or corporate mumbo-jumbo? As your eyelids grow heavy with sleep, you fear your head is going to fall|||may experience a shiver of recognition. It's not just in educational settings. Have you ever attended a meeting where leaders of your organization drone on about some new initiative or corporate mumbo-jumbo? As your eyelids grow heavy with sleep, you fear your head is going to fall
through your interlaced fingers and crash onto the conference table. What is missing from these classrooms and conference rooms, is engagement, a state of being absorbed and alert where you are eager to learn and know more. This week on Hidden Brain, why so many of us feel apathetic at school and at work, and how to cultivate the magic of engagement.
through your interlaced fingers and crash onto the conference table. What is missing from these classrooms and conference rooms, is engagement, a state of being absorbed and alert where you are eager to learn and know more. This week on Hidden Brain, why so many of us feel apathetic at school and at work, and how to cultivate the magic of engagement.|||through your interlaced fingers and crash onto the conference table. What is missing from these classrooms and conference rooms, is engagement, a state of being absorbed and alert where you are eager to learn and know more. This week on Hidden Brain, why so many of us feel apathetic at school and at work, and how to cultivate the magic of engagement.
I remember many days during my school years when I was so bored I would fall asleep in class. But on those very same days, I would find myself alone in a university library at night, pouring over books that had nothing to do with my classwork, oblivious as the hours slipped by. How could the same person be bored to death in one academic setting and completely engaged in another? At the University of Southern California, psychologist and neuroscientist Mary Helen Imordino Yang has explored this question for many years. She studies the science of engagement and motivation. Mary Helen, Imordino-Yang, welcome to Hidden Brain.
I remember many days during my school years when I was so bored I would fall asleep in class. But on those very same days, I would find myself alone in a university library at night, pouring over books that had nothing to do with my classwork, oblivious as the hours slipped by. How could the same person be bored to death in one academic setting and completely engaged in another? At the University of Southern California, psychologist and neuroscientist Mary Helen Imordino Yang has explored this question for many years. She studies the science of engagement and motivation. Mary Helen, Imordino-Yang, welcome to Hidden Brain.|||I remember many days during my school years when I was so bored I would fall asleep in class. But on those very same days, I would find myself alone in a university library at night, pouring over books that had nothing to do with my classwork, oblivious as the hours slipped by. How could the same person be bored to death in one academic setting and completely engaged in another? At the University of Southern California, psychologist and neuroscientist Mary Helen Imordino Yang has explored this question for many years. She studies the science of engagement and motivation. Mary Helen, Imordino-Yang, welcome to Hidden Brain.
Thank you for having me. Mary Helen, you're now a professor of education, but as a kid, I understand that you struggle to feel engaged by school? I really did. I couldn't understand kind of what the point was or what it meant to do things there. And school really didn't feel like it was about learning for me. It felt like it was about doing stuff. And I can hardly describe the sense. of just release on Friday afternoon and the dread on Sunday night through my late elementary especially and early middle school sixth sixth grade year. I finally ended up for a lot of complex reasons for things that were happening at school. I finally ended up just kind of stopping going to
Thank you for having me. Mary Helen, you're now a professor of education, but as a kid, I understand that you struggle to feel engaged by school? I really did. I couldn't understand kind of what the point was or what it meant to do things there. And school really didn't feel like it was about learning for me. It felt like it was about doing stuff. And I can hardly describe the sense. of just release on Friday afternoon and the dread on Sunday night through my late elementary especially and early middle school sixth sixth grade year. I finally ended up for a lot of complex reasons for things that were happening at school. I finally ended up just kind of stopping going to|||Thank you for having me. Mary Helen, you're now a professor of education, but as a kid, I understand that you struggle to feel engaged by school? I really did. I couldn't understand kind of what the point was or what it meant to do things there. And school really didn't feel like it was about learning for me. It felt like it was about doing stuff. And I can hardly describe the sense. of just release on Friday afternoon and the dread on Sunday night through my late elementary especially and early middle school sixth sixth grade year. I finally ended up for a lot of complex reasons for things that were happening at school. I finally ended up just kind of stopping going to
school. I sort of was like a soft dropout about, you know, I just stopped getting up in the morning. And I think my parents just kind of stood back and realized I was doing all kinds of interesting things. We had the great fortune of living in the woods in Connecticut, in a very remote place. And my parents were both from the inner city, one from Detroit, one from Yonkers, New York, right? And they decided they were going to raise their kids on a farm and try to grow what we ate and have animals and all kinds of things. And so I was really deeply involved with running that farm, taking care of the animals. I was playing the piano. I was, you know, running around in the woods, training dogs and, you know, all kinds of things that was keeping me very, very busy.
school. I sort of was like a soft dropout about, you know, I just stopped getting up in the morning. And I think my parents just kind of stood back and realized I was doing all kinds of interesting things. We had the great fortune of living in the woods in Connecticut, in a very remote place. And my parents were both from the inner city, one from Detroit, one from Yonkers, New York, right? And they decided they were going to raise their kids on a farm and try to grow what we ate and have animals and all kinds of things. And so I was really deeply involved with running that farm, taking care of the animals. I was playing the piano. I was, you know, running around in the woods, training dogs and, you know, all kinds of things that was keeping me very, very busy.|||school. I sort of was like a soft dropout about, you know, I just stopped getting up in the morning. And I think my parents just kind of stood back and realized I was doing all kinds of interesting things. We had the great fortune of living in the woods in Connecticut, in a very remote place. And my parents were both from the inner city, one from Detroit, one from Yonkers, New York, right? And they decided they were going to raise their kids on a farm and try to grow what we ate and have animals and all kinds of things. And so I was really deeply involved with running that farm, taking care of the animals. I was playing the piano. I was, you know, running around in the woods, training dogs and, you know, all kinds of things that was keeping me very, very busy.
I understand that at one point your grandmother once discovered something unusual in her refrigerator that you had left there. Tell me that story, Mary Helen. Oh, God, I was a little older. And that actually represents a turning point in my education, I think. My parents had the resources to be able to find a different kind of education. system for me. So they moved me the following year into a private school that had, as it turns out, much more rigorous and interesting academics in addition to all kinds of theater and art and singing and all these other things that I was very interested in. And so I started there
I understand that at one point your grandmother once discovered something unusual in her refrigerator that you had left there. Tell me that story, Mary Helen. Oh, God, I was a little older. And that actually represents a turning point in my education, I think. My parents had the resources to be able to find a different kind of education. system for me. So they moved me the following year into a private school that had, as it turns out, much more rigorous and interesting academics in addition to all kinds of theater and art and singing and all these other things that I was very interested in. And so I started there|||I understand that at one point your grandmother once discovered something unusual in her refrigerator that you had left there. Tell me that story, Mary Helen. Oh, God, I was a little older. And that actually represents a turning point in my education, I think. My parents had the resources to be able to find a different kind of education. system for me. So they moved me the following year into a private school that had, as it turns out, much more rigorous and interesting academics in addition to all kinds of theater and art and singing and all these other things that I was very interested in. And so I started there
in seventh grade and I just really fell in love with science class. You know, thank you, Mrs. Susan Lundgren if you're still out there for really like teaching us so much interesting stuff and we were doing all these laboratory experiments where we were you know dissecting all kinds of things from flowers and worms to fish and that really pulled me in so for my seventh grade um science project I I decided to try to um you know figure out how a site works how we see in the eyeball what the eyeball is structured like and so you know I read all about it and my dad went with me and he basically got a bunch of cow eyeballs harvested out of some cows who had been slaughtered and we brought home this bag of eyeballs for me to dissect and I put it in
in seventh grade and I just really fell in love with science class. You know, thank you, Mrs. Susan Lundgren if you're still out there for really like teaching us so much interesting stuff and we were doing all these laboratory experiments where we were you know dissecting all kinds of things from flowers and worms to fish and that really pulled me in so for my seventh grade um science project I I decided to try to um you know figure out how a site works how we see in the eyeball what the eyeball is structured like and so you know I read all about it and my dad went with me and he basically got a bunch of cow eyeballs harvested out of some cows who had been slaughtered and we brought home this bag of eyeballs for me to dissect and I put it in|||in seventh grade and I just really fell in love with science class. You know, thank you, Mrs. Susan Lundgren if you're still out there for really like teaching us so much interesting stuff and we were doing all these laboratory experiments where we were you know dissecting all kinds of things from flowers and worms to fish and that really pulled me in so for my seventh grade um science project I I decided to try to um you know figure out how a site works how we see in the eyeball what the eyeball is structured like and so you know I read all about it and my dad went with me and he basically got a bunch of cow eyeballs harvested out of some cows who had been slaughtered and we brought home this bag of eyeballs for me to dissect and I put it in
the refrigerator and my poor grandmother came to visit and, you know, was like, what's this in the refrigerator and realized it was a bag full of eyeballs, but I did go on to take those eyeballs apart and really, you know, try to figure out one of these different parts, how do they relate to the model I have here in one of those roles they're playing in vision. And, you know, I really just loved to be sort of self-directed and designing my own project and kind of digging in on it, but also being accountable to share what I had learned in a more rigorous academic way at school. So I really thrived that year. I understand that you came.
the refrigerator and my poor grandmother came to visit and, you know, was like, what's this in the refrigerator and realized it was a bag full of eyeballs, but I did go on to take those eyeballs apart and really, you know, try to figure out one of these different parts, how do they relate to the model I have here in one of those roles they're playing in vision. And, you know, I really just loved to be sort of self-directed and designing my own project and kind of digging in on it, but also being accountable to share what I had learned in a more rigorous academic way at school. So I really thrived that year. I understand that you came.|||the refrigerator and my poor grandmother came to visit and, you know, was like, what's this in the refrigerator and realized it was a bag full of eyeballs, but I did go on to take those eyeballs apart and really, you know, try to figure out one of these different parts, how do they relate to the model I have here in one of those roles they're playing in vision. And, you know, I really just loved to be sort of self-directed and designing my own project and kind of digging in on it, but also being accountable to share what I had learned in a more rigorous academic way at school. So I really thrived that year. I understand that you came.
to be deeply interested in woodworking and boat building. How did you discover this passion, Mary Helen? Oh, I always loved to build things. And, you know, growing up on this, like, sort of kind of sort of little farm thing in the woods, right? You know, we built it all ourselves. So when there was a hurricane, a bunch of trees fell down and we had those turned into lumber and boards, and we had to build the fences, right, for pastures to have sheep and things in them and horses, and we built a barn. And I was tagging along behind this elderly Yankee, a gentleman who was a really master builder, who he was an expert in stone walls and in building things. And I was following along behind him as his assistant. And so from there, I really got into
to be deeply interested in woodworking and boat building. How did you discover this passion, Mary Helen? Oh, I always loved to build things. And, you know, growing up on this, like, sort of kind of sort of little farm thing in the woods, right? You know, we built it all ourselves. So when there was a hurricane, a bunch of trees fell down and we had those turned into lumber and boards, and we had to build the fences, right, for pastures to have sheep and things in them and horses, and we built a barn. And I was tagging along behind this elderly Yankee, a gentleman who was a really master builder, who he was an expert in stone walls and in building things. And I was following along behind him as his assistant. And so from there, I really got into|||to be deeply interested in woodworking and boat building. How did you discover this passion, Mary Helen? Oh, I always loved to build things. And, you know, growing up on this, like, sort of kind of sort of little farm thing in the woods, right? You know, we built it all ourselves. So when there was a hurricane, a bunch of trees fell down and we had those turned into lumber and boards, and we had to build the fences, right, for pastures to have sheep and things in them and horses, and we built a barn. And I was tagging along behind this elderly Yankee, a gentleman who was a really master builder, who he was an expert in stone walls and in building things. And I was following along behind him as his assistant. And so from there, I really got into
woodworking growing up. I also got very interested in boat building. building, wooden boat building for a while. And I went to Russia and to Kenya, you know, different places in the world where people were building traditional wooden boats of different sorts and just was trying to work with people there, with men there, to build these things, to understand how they constructed these, you know, beautiful straight boats that go in a line and that are controllable out of wood, that squirrelly mangrove, you know, I just found that really compelling. In her early 20s, Mary Helen began teaching science at a public school.
woodworking growing up. I also got very interested in boat building. building, wooden boat building for a while. And I went to Russia and to Kenya, you know, different places in the world where people were building traditional wooden boats of different sorts and just was trying to work with people there, with men there, to build these things, to understand how they constructed these, you know, beautiful straight boats that go in a line and that are controllable out of wood, that squirrelly mangrove, you know, I just found that really compelling. In her early 20s, Mary Helen began teaching science at a public school.|||woodworking growing up. I also got very interested in boat building. building, wooden boat building for a while. And I went to Russia and to Kenya, you know, different places in the world where people were building traditional wooden boats of different sorts and just was trying to work with people there, with men there, to build these things, to understand how they constructed these, you know, beautiful straight boats that go in a line and that are controllable out of wood, that squirrelly mangrove, you know, I just found that really compelling. In her early 20s, Mary Helen began teaching science at a public school.
The school had lots of immigrant families from Africa. She was teaching them about evolution. What fascinated me was that the kids started to ask me questions about why, when we talked about early humans and hominids, why they were always depicted with dark skin, like they looked like black people. And I remember in particular one girl, you know, bravely raising her hand and it just struck me that all the other kids were kind of pushing her on, like, yeah, yeah, ask the question, asking me, why is that the case? Why do these early hominids always, why are they depicted with dark skin? And of course, they were on the equator
The school had lots of immigrant families from Africa. She was teaching them about evolution. What fascinated me was that the kids started to ask me questions about why, when we talked about early humans and hominids, why they were always depicted with dark skin, like they looked like black people. And I remember in particular one girl, you know, bravely raising her hand and it just struck me that all the other kids were kind of pushing her on, like, yeah, yeah, ask the question, asking me, why is that the case? Why do these early hominids always, why are they depicted with dark skin? And of course, they were on the equator|||The school had lots of immigrant families from Africa. She was teaching them about evolution. What fascinated me was that the kids started to ask me questions about why, when we talked about early humans and hominids, why they were always depicted with dark skin, like they looked like black people. And I remember in particular one girl, you know, bravely raising her hand and it just struck me that all the other kids were kind of pushing her on, like, yeah, yeah, ask the question, asking me, why is that the case? Why do these early hominids always, why are they depicted with dark skin? And of course, they were on the equator
where without dark skin, you would fry, right? You would have skin cancer, you'd be sunburned. And I think it was a turning point moment because the kids suddenly realized that the concept of evolution and of adaptation to your environment was applying to them as well in that context. They were seeing themselves adapt to a new environment. They were looking around at each other and seeing how they were different from one another. And they realized that the reasons we are the way we are is something to do with where we come from and how we've adapted ourselves to fit into the world. and to flourish in the spaces in which our ancestors came from. And that became the entree into conversations about race, about identity, but also about individual variability,
where without dark skin, you would fry, right? You would have skin cancer, you'd be sunburned. And I think it was a turning point moment because the kids suddenly realized that the concept of evolution and of adaptation to your environment was applying to them as well in that context. They were seeing themselves adapt to a new environment. They were looking around at each other and seeing how they were different from one another. And they realized that the reasons we are the way we are is something to do with where we come from and how we've adapted ourselves to fit into the world. and to flourish in the spaces in which our ancestors came from. And that became the entree into conversations about race, about identity, but also about individual variability,|||where without dark skin, you would fry, right? You would have skin cancer, you'd be sunburned. And I think it was a turning point moment because the kids suddenly realized that the concept of evolution and of adaptation to your environment was applying to them as well in that context. They were seeing themselves adapt to a new environment. They were looking around at each other and seeing how they were different from one another. And they realized that the reasons we are the way we are is something to do with where we come from and how we've adapted ourselves to fit into the world. and to flourish in the spaces in which our ancestors came from. And that became the entree into conversations about race, about identity, but also about individual variability,
about the ways in which development and experience shape who you are. I understand that after this experience in the classroom, these students also became more engaged with the science. They actually wanted to learn more because now they're not just learning about abstract concepts. They're learning about things that they feel they have a direct connection. connection to. Yeah, they became very deeply interested, some of them, in really the ways that science could help them explore the world. I remember one girl who went for the first time, we were kind of near the beach, but she had never been to the coast before, and her parents
about the ways in which development and experience shape who you are. I understand that after this experience in the classroom, these students also became more engaged with the science. They actually wanted to learn more because now they're not just learning about abstract concepts. They're learning about things that they feel they have a direct connection. connection to. Yeah, they became very deeply interested, some of them, in really the ways that science could help them explore the world. I remember one girl who went for the first time, we were kind of near the beach, but she had never been to the coast before, and her parents|||about the ways in which development and experience shape who you are. I understand that after this experience in the classroom, these students also became more engaged with the science. They actually wanted to learn more because now they're not just learning about abstract concepts. They're learning about things that they feel they have a direct connection. connection to. Yeah, they became very deeply interested, some of them, in really the ways that science could help them explore the world. I remember one girl who went for the first time, we were kind of near the beach, but she had never been to the coast before, and her parents
took her on a weekend excursion to the beach, and she came back eagerly on Monday morning with a coffee can with snails in it and was showing me like, look, they're alive. Like, these things were at the beach. So I think they really took some of the concepts and tried to use that approach to explore their world. And that was incredibly powerful. So even as your students were, you know, using the science and thinking about ways that the science could apply to their lives, I also see you as a young teacher basically looking at these students and saying, some light bulb has gone off here. You know, these students were perhaps not as engaged earlier, but now their eyes are alight with excitement. They are basically trying to apply this to their own lives.
took her on a weekend excursion to the beach, and she came back eagerly on Monday morning with a coffee can with snails in it and was showing me like, look, they're alive. Like, these things were at the beach. So I think they really took some of the concepts and tried to use that approach to explore their world. And that was incredibly powerful. So even as your students were, you know, using the science and thinking about ways that the science could apply to their lives, I also see you as a young teacher basically looking at these students and saying, some light bulb has gone off here. You know, these students were perhaps not as engaged earlier, but now their eyes are alight with excitement. They are basically trying to apply this to their own lives.|||took her on a weekend excursion to the beach, and she came back eagerly on Monday morning with a coffee can with snails in it and was showing me like, look, they're alive. Like, these things were at the beach. So I think they really took some of the concepts and tried to use that approach to explore their world. And that was incredibly powerful. So even as your students were, you know, using the science and thinking about ways that the science could apply to their lives, I also see you as a young teacher basically looking at these students and saying, some light bulb has gone off here. You know, these students were perhaps not as engaged earlier, but now their eyes are alight with excitement. They are basically trying to apply this to their own lives.
At what point did you have the insight that you were seeing some important clue to the science of engagement? I mean, kids were running into my classroom at, you know, 7 o'clock in the morning with a can of snails and some seawater and saying, like, look, look, they're alive, right? I think the engagement really showed itself in the fact that kids were running off on their own, designing their own things and trying to use the resources I was providing them to do the stuff. were imagining. We filled the course with projects. I gave kids a huge amount of leeway in what kinds of activities they would do. Like I set out a goal, we're studying astronomy now, here's what it looks like. But then different kids had to figure out for themselves. What did they want to do in that space? And I really kind of tried to throw the ball back in their court and make them in charge of deciding what did they want to do in this space.
At what point did you have the insight that you were seeing some important clue to the science of engagement? I mean, kids were running into my classroom at, you know, 7 o'clock in the morning with a can of snails and some seawater and saying, like, look, look, they're alive, right? I think the engagement really showed itself in the fact that kids were running off on their own, designing their own things and trying to use the resources I was providing them to do the stuff. were imagining. We filled the course with projects. I gave kids a huge amount of leeway in what kinds of activities they would do. Like I set out a goal, we're studying astronomy now, here's what it looks like. But then different kids had to figure out for themselves. What did they want to do in that space? And I really kind of tried to throw the ball back in their court and make them in charge of deciding what did they want to do in this space.|||At what point did you have the insight that you were seeing some important clue to the science of engagement? I mean, kids were running into my classroom at, you know, 7 o'clock in the morning with a can of snails and some seawater and saying, like, look, look, they're alive, right? I think the engagement really showed itself in the fact that kids were running off on their own, designing their own things and trying to use the resources I was providing them to do the stuff. were imagining. We filled the course with projects. I gave kids a huge amount of leeway in what kinds of activities they would do. Like I set out a goal, we're studying astronomy now, here's what it looks like. But then different kids had to figure out for themselves. What did they want to do in that space? And I really kind of tried to throw the ball back in their court and make them in charge of deciding what did they want to do in this space.
How were they going to design this project I'd suggested? You know, and I was teaching them to use the microscopes that I found in the closet. I was teaching them to use some of the other scientific instrumentation that we had floating around. And then they were designing activities for themselves, you know, that rift off of the things I was introducing them to in the class. What is it that makes the very same person bored and unlawful? unmotivated in one setting and a flame with curiosity in another. When we come back, searching for the magic recipe for deep engagement. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantham.
How were they going to design this project I'd suggested? You know, and I was teaching them to use the microscopes that I found in the closet. I was teaching them to use some of the other scientific instrumentation that we had floating around. And then they were designing activities for themselves, you know, that rift off of the things I was introducing them to in the class. What is it that makes the very same person bored and unlawful? unmotivated in one setting and a flame with curiosity in another. When we come back, searching for the magic recipe for deep engagement. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantham.|||How were they going to design this project I'd suggested? You know, and I was teaching them to use the microscopes that I found in the closet. I was teaching them to use some of the other scientific instrumentation that we had floating around. And then they were designing activities for themselves, you know, that rift off of the things I was introducing them to in the class. What is it that makes the very same person bored and unlawful? unmotivated in one setting and a flame with curiosity in another. When we come back, searching for the magic recipe for deep engagement. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantham.
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Mary Helen Imordino-Yang is a psychologist and neuroscientist at the University of Southern California. She studies what makes students engaged and motivated or disengaged and disaffected. Mary Helen, as a way of seeking answers to the questions raised by your own experiences of learning and teaching, you became a researcher working under the eminent neuroscientist Antonio DiMasio.
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Mary Helen Imordino-Yang is a psychologist and neuroscientist at the University of Southern California. She studies what makes students engaged and motivated or disengaged and disaffected. Mary Helen, as a way of seeking answers to the questions raised by your own experiences of learning and teaching, you became a researcher working under the eminent neuroscientist Antonio DiMasio.|||This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Mary Helen Imordino-Yang is a psychologist and neuroscientist at the University of Southern California. She studies what makes students engaged and motivated or disengaged and disaffected. Mary Helen, as a way of seeking answers to the questions raised by your own experiences of learning and teaching, you became a researcher working under the eminent neuroscientist Antonio DiMasio.
The two of you were attempting to understand engagement on a neurological level. Now, he had tried various ways of evoking engagement in the lab, but nothing seemed to be working. Yeah. So Antonio, when I first met him and Hana, his collaborator and wife, were deeply interested in trying to understand how the human brain creates engagement and emotion around ideas, around social relationships and values and beliefs. And it was remarkably difficult to genuinely elicit those kinds of complex feelings in a laboratory setting. What ended up working just remarkably well was to bring together stories of real people's lives from around the world, people in a variety of complex situations, and compose these stories into little mini-documentaries that I would share with the participants in our experiments in a private
The two of you were attempting to understand engagement on a neurological level. Now, he had tried various ways of evoking engagement in the lab, but nothing seemed to be working. Yeah. So Antonio, when I first met him and Hana, his collaborator and wife, were deeply interested in trying to understand how the human brain creates engagement and emotion around ideas, around social relationships and values and beliefs. And it was remarkably difficult to genuinely elicit those kinds of complex feelings in a laboratory setting. What ended up working just remarkably well was to bring together stories of real people's lives from around the world, people in a variety of complex situations, and compose these stories into little mini-documentaries that I would share with the participants in our experiments in a private|||The two of you were attempting to understand engagement on a neurological level. Now, he had tried various ways of evoking engagement in the lab, but nothing seemed to be working. Yeah. So Antonio, when I first met him and Hana, his collaborator and wife, were deeply interested in trying to understand how the human brain creates engagement and emotion around ideas, around social relationships and values and beliefs. And it was remarkably difficult to genuinely elicit those kinds of complex feelings in a laboratory setting. What ended up working just remarkably well was to bring together stories of real people's lives from around the world, people in a variety of complex situations, and compose these stories into little mini-documentaries that I would share with the participants in our experiments in a private
two-hour-long interview where I would show them a small two-minute to five-minute document. and tell them the story of someone's situation, and then just ask them, how does this person's story make you feel? And from that, people began to really start to actively engage with and show us, exteriorize their own meaning-making process, the way in which they made sense of what they'd heard and learned, and then went from there to begin to tell stories about what it meant to them and how they felt. about it. And we moved people to the MRI scanner after that and scanned their brain activity. We also recorded the activity in their bodies, their heart rate, their breathing, called psychophysiological recording at the same time. And we had them watch the stories again in the scanner and push buttons in real time to tell us how emotionally engaged they were with that
two-hour-long interview where I would show them a small two-minute to five-minute document. and tell them the story of someone's situation, and then just ask them, how does this person's story make you feel? And from that, people began to really start to actively engage with and show us, exteriorize their own meaning-making process, the way in which they made sense of what they'd heard and learned, and then went from there to begin to tell stories about what it meant to them and how they felt. about it. And we moved people to the MRI scanner after that and scanned their brain activity. We also recorded the activity in their bodies, their heart rate, their breathing, called psychophysiological recording at the same time. And we had them watch the stories again in the scanner and push buttons in real time to tell us how emotionally engaged they were with that|||two-hour-long interview where I would show them a small two-minute to five-minute document. and tell them the story of someone's situation, and then just ask them, how does this person's story make you feel? And from that, people began to really start to actively engage with and show us, exteriorize their own meaning-making process, the way in which they made sense of what they'd heard and learned, and then went from there to begin to tell stories about what it meant to them and how they felt. about it. And we moved people to the MRI scanner after that and scanned their brain activity. We also recorded the activity in their bodies, their heart rate, their breathing, called psychophysiological recording at the same time. And we had them watch the stories again in the scanner and push buttons in real time to tell us how emotionally engaged they were with that
story at that moment. And what we were able to do was design a method. in which we could relate patterns of brain activity and body activity to expressions of emotional engagement that they are subjectively telling us they're having in real time. And look at how those patterns were related to the ways in which they made meaning of the story and narratized their own experience of thinking about the story in the interview. So one of the video clips you showed was of Malala Yousafzai, who described what it was like to seek an education in a region of Pakistan that was under the control of the Taliban?
story at that moment. And what we were able to do was design a method. in which we could relate patterns of brain activity and body activity to expressions of emotional engagement that they are subjectively telling us they're having in real time. And look at how those patterns were related to the ways in which they made meaning of the story and narratized their own experience of thinking about the story in the interview. So one of the video clips you showed was of Malala Yousafzai, who described what it was like to seek an education in a region of Pakistan that was under the control of the Taliban?|||story at that moment. And what we were able to do was design a method. in which we could relate patterns of brain activity and body activity to expressions of emotional engagement that they are subjectively telling us they're having in real time. And look at how those patterns were related to the ways in which they made meaning of the story and narratized their own experience of thinking about the story in the interview. So one of the video clips you showed was of Malala Yousafzai, who described what it was like to seek an education in a region of Pakistan that was under the control of the Taliban?
In the war, the girls are going to their schools freely and there is no fail. But in Savat, when we go to our school, we are very afraid of Taliban. He will kill us. He will throw acid on our face and he can do anything. So you showed this video to one teenager named Isela.
In the war, the girls are going to their schools freely and there is no fail. But in Savat, when we go to our school, we are very afraid of Taliban. He will kill us. He will throw acid on our face and he can do anything. So you showed this video to one teenager named Isela.|||In the war, the girls are going to their schools freely and there is no fail. But in Savat, when we go to our school, we are very afraid of Taliban. He will kill us. He will throw acid on our face and he can do anything. So you showed this video to one teenager named Isela.
How did it make her feel? What did she say, Mary Helen? What Asela said, I think, was quite extraordinary and turned out to reveal a kind of pattern of thinking that many adolescents engaged in different ways and that we discovered was very important to both their brain growth and their social growth. What Acella said was first along the lines of,
How did it make her feel? What did she say, Mary Helen? What Asela said, I think, was quite extraordinary and turned out to reveal a kind of pattern of thinking that many adolescents engaged in different ways and that we discovered was very important to both their brain growth and their social growth. What Acella said was first along the lines of,|||How did it make her feel? What did she say, Mary Helen? What Asela said, I think, was quite extraordinary and turned out to reveal a kind of pattern of thinking that many adolescents engaged in different ways and that we discovered was very important to both their brain growth and their social growth. What Acella said was first along the lines of,
well, this story makes me feel very upset. It's going to be so difficult for her. She wants to be a doctor, but it's very difficult because she's not allowed to go to school and that's frightening and it makes me sad. But then she paused and that pause is very important neurologically because we think what's happening is she's shifting herself into another mode of engagement where she's leveraging systems of the brain that are involved in consciousness, in autobiographical memory, in storytelling, and beliefs and values. And what she's
well, this story makes me feel very upset. It's going to be so difficult for her. She wants to be a doctor, but it's very difficult because she's not allowed to go to school and that's frightening and it makes me sad. But then she paused and that pause is very important neurologically because we think what's happening is she's shifting herself into another mode of engagement where she's leveraging systems of the brain that are involved in consciousness, in autobiographical memory, in storytelling, and beliefs and values. And what she's|||well, this story makes me feel very upset. It's going to be so difficult for her. She wants to be a doctor, but it's very difficult because she's not allowed to go to school and that's frightening and it makes me sad. But then she paused and that pause is very important neurologically because we think what's happening is she's shifting herself into another mode of engagement where she's leveraging systems of the brain that are involved in consciousness, in autobiographical memory, in storytelling, and beliefs and values. And what she's
said next was astounding. She said, it's crazy how it's that powerful. She says something like, it makes me think about my own journey in education and how I want to go to college and hopefully be a scientist someday, right? So she was likening her own experience to that girl's experience to see the similarity. But then she moves even beyond that and says, I guess what really hits me, like what the emotion is about now is how not everyone's able to get this chance to go forward with their life and get an education and do what they want to do with their life. And she says, it's not right. She moves from analyzing this one girl's sad situation, which is very difficult and makes
said next was astounding. She said, it's crazy how it's that powerful. She says something like, it makes me think about my own journey in education and how I want to go to college and hopefully be a scientist someday, right? So she was likening her own experience to that girl's experience to see the similarity. But then she moves even beyond that and says, I guess what really hits me, like what the emotion is about now is how not everyone's able to get this chance to go forward with their life and get an education and do what they want to do with their life. And she says, it's not right. She moves from analyzing this one girl's sad situation, which is very difficult and makes|||said next was astounding. She said, it's crazy how it's that powerful. She says something like, it makes me think about my own journey in education and how I want to go to college and hopefully be a scientist someday, right? So she was likening her own experience to that girl's experience to see the similarity. But then she moves even beyond that and says, I guess what really hits me, like what the emotion is about now is how not everyone's able to get this chance to go forward with their life and get an education and do what they want to do with their life. And she says, it's not right. She moves from analyzing this one girl's sad situation, which is very difficult and makes
her sad, to this much more powerful story about what it means for what's right in the world, what happens, what shouldn't happen, what could happen, and who she and that girl both are in the space of the broader world and what that means for what's right. she has invented morality out of a story that was a specific example. What makes this powerful is, of course, she is relating the story she is hearing to her own life. So she's not just seeing it as this other girl's story over there, but she's saying this is my story too. She's saying it's my story too, but she even goes beyond that.
her sad, to this much more powerful story about what it means for what's right in the world, what happens, what shouldn't happen, what could happen, and who she and that girl both are in the space of the broader world and what that means for what's right. she has invented morality out of a story that was a specific example. What makes this powerful is, of course, she is relating the story she is hearing to her own life. So she's not just seeing it as this other girl's story over there, but she's saying this is my story too. She's saying it's my story too, but she even goes beyond that.|||her sad, to this much more powerful story about what it means for what's right in the world, what happens, what shouldn't happen, what could happen, and who she and that girl both are in the space of the broader world and what that means for what's right. she has invented morality out of a story that was a specific example. What makes this powerful is, of course, she is relating the story she is hearing to her own life. So she's not just seeing it as this other girl's story over there, but she's saying this is my story too. She's saying it's my story too, but she even goes beyond that.
She goes all the way toward the end and says, it's not right. It makes me feel upset that other people, who live in certain parts of the world where they don't want people to learn are trying to hold them back, right? She starts to understand that both she and this girl are part of an even bigger world. So she goes
She goes all the way toward the end and says, it's not right. It makes me feel upset that other people, who live in certain parts of the world where they don't want people to learn are trying to hold them back, right? She starts to understand that both she and this girl are part of an even bigger world. So she goes|||She goes all the way toward the end and says, it's not right. It makes me feel upset that other people, who live in certain parts of the world where they don't want people to learn are trying to hold them back, right? She starts to understand that both she and this girl are part of an even bigger world. So she goes
from that girl to her own story to something even bigger than the two of them. And she ends by saying, everyone everywhere should have the chance. I mean, all human beings should be able to live free and choose their life future. So she has invented an idea, a belief, of value
from that girl to her own story to something even bigger than the two of them. And she ends by saying, everyone everywhere should have the chance. I mean, all human beings should be able to live free and choose their life future. So she has invented an idea, a belief, of value|||from that girl to her own story to something even bigger than the two of them. And she ends by saying, everyone everywhere should have the chance. I mean, all human beings should be able to live free and choose their life future. So she has invented an idea, a belief, of value
about how the world should be for everyone from explaining and making sense of one girl's story, relating it to her own story, relating it to the possible future story she had hoped to invent for herself, and from there thinking about what's right or good or possible everywhere for everyone. like Issella connected with these stories in a way that went beyond the mere facts, you came to call this kind of engagement transcendent thinking. What do you mean by the term? Issella engaged in this thing we're calling transcendent thinking because her thinking moved from the current context
about how the world should be for everyone from explaining and making sense of one girl's story, relating it to her own story, relating it to the possible future story she had hoped to invent for herself, and from there thinking about what's right or good or possible everywhere for everyone. like Issella connected with these stories in a way that went beyond the mere facts, you came to call this kind of engagement transcendent thinking. What do you mean by the term? Issella engaged in this thing we're calling transcendent thinking because her thinking moved from the current context|||about how the world should be for everyone from explaining and making sense of one girl's story, relating it to her own story, relating it to the possible future story she had hoped to invent for herself, and from there thinking about what's right or good or possible everywhere for everyone. like Issella connected with these stories in a way that went beyond the mere facts, you came to call this kind of engagement transcendent thinking. What do you mean by the term? Issella engaged in this thing we're calling transcendent thinking because her thinking moved from the current context
and transcended that context to think also about what these examples mean for bigger ideas, for what's right or good, for how instant, work, for the intentions behind the institutions and the settings and the situations that she learned about, for the values, the morals, the beliefs, for the possible futures, for the historical interpretations, for the identities that they invoke. Kids did this in many different ways. But the heart of transcendent thinking is that kids became deeply engaged with thinking about something bigger than what was directly in front of them.
and transcended that context to think also about what these examples mean for bigger ideas, for what's right or good, for how instant, work, for the intentions behind the institutions and the settings and the situations that she learned about, for the values, the morals, the beliefs, for the possible futures, for the historical interpretations, for the identities that they invoke. Kids did this in many different ways. But the heart of transcendent thinking is that kids became deeply engaged with thinking about something bigger than what was directly in front of them.|||and transcended that context to think also about what these examples mean for bigger ideas, for what's right or good, for how instant, work, for the intentions behind the institutions and the settings and the situations that she learned about, for the values, the morals, the beliefs, for the possible futures, for the historical interpretations, for the identities that they invoke. Kids did this in many different ways. But the heart of transcendent thinking is that kids became deeply engaged with thinking about something bigger than what was directly in front of them.
You ran a similar kind of study with teenagers in urban Los Angeles and you asked them to think about crime in their neighborhoods. Tell me about that study and what you found there, Mary Helen. Right. So we asked kids who were not involved in any kind of criminal activity, who were not under any disciplinary action at school, who were passing all of their classes, who were from stable home situations.
You ran a similar kind of study with teenagers in urban Los Angeles and you asked them to think about crime in their neighborhoods. Tell me about that study and what you found there, Mary Helen. Right. So we asked kids who were not involved in any kind of criminal activity, who were not under any disciplinary action at school, who were passing all of their classes, who were from stable home situations.|||You ran a similar kind of study with teenagers in urban Los Angeles and you asked them to think about crime in their neighborhoods. Tell me about that study and what you found there, Mary Helen. Right. So we asked kids who were not involved in any kind of criminal activity, who were not under any disciplinary action at school, who were passing all of their classes, who were from stable home situations.
So kids who were, you know, doing fine, as my grandmother would have said, right? We asked those kids about the things that they'd witnessed and seen in their neighborhoods. And they told us about a range of scary, dangerous criminal activity of various sorts. But we didn't stop there. We then went through with them and said, okay, so you said you saw a drug deal, or you said you saw somebody get arrested, or you said you saw somebody vandalized something, or somebody get in a fight. Why do you think that happens? And how do you think the different actors in that scenario felt?
So kids who were, you know, doing fine, as my grandmother would have said, right? We asked those kids about the things that they'd witnessed and seen in their neighborhoods. And they told us about a range of scary, dangerous criminal activity of various sorts. But we didn't stop there. We then went through with them and said, okay, so you said you saw a drug deal, or you said you saw somebody get arrested, or you said you saw somebody vandalized something, or somebody get in a fight. Why do you think that happens? And how do you think the different actors in that scenario felt?|||So kids who were, you know, doing fine, as my grandmother would have said, right? We asked those kids about the things that they'd witnessed and seen in their neighborhoods. And they told us about a range of scary, dangerous criminal activity of various sorts. But we didn't stop there. We then went through with them and said, okay, so you said you saw a drug deal, or you said you saw somebody get arrested, or you said you saw somebody vandalized something, or somebody get in a fight. Why do you think that happens? And how do you think the different actors in that scenario felt?
And how do you think the cop felt? How do you think the little kid watching felt, right? And then we asked them a really pivotal question. We said, imagine you were in charge and the people in your neighborhood who run things would do whatever you asked them to do as the new policy to try to make your neighborhood a better, safer place.
And how do you think the cop felt? How do you think the little kid watching felt, right? And then we asked them a really pivotal question. We said, imagine you were in charge and the people in your neighborhood who run things would do whatever you asked them to do as the new policy to try to make your neighborhood a better, safer place.|||And how do you think the cop felt? How do you think the little kid watching felt, right? And then we asked them a really pivotal question. We said, imagine you were in charge and the people in your neighborhood who run things would do whatever you asked them to do as the new policy to try to make your neighborhood a better, safer place.
What would you advise them to do? And there again, we saw an amazing range of answers where some kids stayed sort of in the immediate moment saying, well, these people are bad people, they do bad things, they lose control of their emotion, they get angry, and they just do something before they think. And they deserve to be rounded up or punished in some way, and that's how you're going to control things, right? Or there's nothing that can be done to control it, said one kid. This is just how these people are. Stay away from them. Other kids went beyond this to say, well, I think you have to think about the bigger picture. I think you have to think about the person's history, one kid told me.
What would you advise them to do? And there again, we saw an amazing range of answers where some kids stayed sort of in the immediate moment saying, well, these people are bad people, they do bad things, they lose control of their emotion, they get angry, and they just do something before they think. And they deserve to be rounded up or punished in some way, and that's how you're going to control things, right? Or there's nothing that can be done to control it, said one kid. This is just how these people are. Stay away from them. Other kids went beyond this to say, well, I think you have to think about the bigger picture. I think you have to think about the person's history, one kid told me.|||What would you advise them to do? And there again, we saw an amazing range of answers where some kids stayed sort of in the immediate moment saying, well, these people are bad people, they do bad things, they lose control of their emotion, they get angry, and they just do something before they think. And they deserve to be rounded up or punished in some way, and that's how you're going to control things, right? Or there's nothing that can be done to control it, said one kid. This is just how these people are. Stay away from them. Other kids went beyond this to say, well, I think you have to think about the bigger picture. I think you have to think about the person's history, one kid told me.
He said something like, everyone has a history, everyone has a story. And that changes who they are because of the way they've lived in their life. So if we really wanted to do something to make the neighborhood better, we should think about why these people feel the way they do that they get themselves into these situations. and he went on to tell me about his own family and how he had been loved and safe, but maybe these people hadn't been. And maybe that's where we should focus our efforts if we wanted to make the neighborhood better. So in transcendent thinking, you're not just considering the facts in front of you,
He said something like, everyone has a history, everyone has a story. And that changes who they are because of the way they've lived in their life. So if we really wanted to do something to make the neighborhood better, we should think about why these people feel the way they do that they get themselves into these situations. and he went on to tell me about his own family and how he had been loved and safe, but maybe these people hadn't been. And maybe that's where we should focus our efforts if we wanted to make the neighborhood better. So in transcendent thinking, you're not just considering the facts in front of you,|||He said something like, everyone has a history, everyone has a story. And that changes who they are because of the way they've lived in their life. So if we really wanted to do something to make the neighborhood better, we should think about why these people feel the way they do that they get themselves into these situations. and he went on to tell me about his own family and how he had been loved and safe, but maybe these people hadn't been. And maybe that's where we should focus our efforts if we wanted to make the neighborhood better. So in transcendent thinking, you're not just considering the facts in front of you,
but you're trying to see how those facts connect with other facts, and perhaps more important, how individual facts are like trees in a forest, and you're not just seeing the trees, you're actually trying to see the forest. That's right. And you're trying to understand what makes the forest go, right? You're trying to see the hidden forces that are not immediately obvious when you just look at the forest. You're trying to understand gravity and osmosis and climate, right? You're trying to understand the bigger things that are behind the forest, but that are not immediately obvious when you just look at it. Do we know what's happening in the brain when kids are engaged in this kind of transcendent thinking, Mary Helen? Yes. So when the kids moved into the MRI scanner and thought about these same stories again, we were able to look across a young person's activity profile and match up particular time periods where they were telling us they were thinking about a particular story that they had reacted to in the interview in a transcendent way. as compared to the stories they had reacted to in a more concrete way.
but you're trying to see how those facts connect with other facts, and perhaps more important, how individual facts are like trees in a forest, and you're not just seeing the trees, you're actually trying to see the forest. That's right. And you're trying to understand what makes the forest go, right? You're trying to see the hidden forces that are not immediately obvious when you just look at the forest. You're trying to understand gravity and osmosis and climate, right? You're trying to understand the bigger things that are behind the forest, but that are not immediately obvious when you just look at it. Do we know what's happening in the brain when kids are engaged in this kind of transcendent thinking, Mary Helen? Yes. So when the kids moved into the MRI scanner and thought about these same stories again, we were able to look across a young person's activity profile and match up particular time periods where they were telling us they were thinking about a particular story that they had reacted to in the interview in a transcendent way. as compared to the stories they had reacted to in a more concrete way.|||but you're trying to see how those facts connect with other facts, and perhaps more important, how individual facts are like trees in a forest, and you're not just seeing the trees, you're actually trying to see the forest. That's right. And you're trying to understand what makes the forest go, right? You're trying to see the hidden forces that are not immediately obvious when you just look at the forest. You're trying to understand gravity and osmosis and climate, right? You're trying to understand the bigger things that are behind the forest, but that are not immediately obvious when you just look at it. Do we know what's happening in the brain when kids are engaged in this kind of transcendent thinking, Mary Helen? Yes. So when the kids moved into the MRI scanner and thought about these same stories again, we were able to look across a young person's activity profile and match up particular time periods where they were telling us they were thinking about a particular story that they had reacted to in the interview in a transcendent way. as compared to the stories they had reacted to in a more concrete way.
And so what we found is that there were particular network properties of the brain that systematically came active and deactive in this coordinated pattern that was driven by the kid's expression of strong emotion and that organized the basic networks in the brain that led to transcendent thinking. What were these networks in the brain, Mary Helen? Describe some of these to me. So there were three main networks involved at the level that we're analyzing. Of course, the brain is infinitely complex.
And so what we found is that there were particular network properties of the brain that systematically came active and deactive in this coordinated pattern that was driven by the kid's expression of strong emotion and that organized the basic networks in the brain that led to transcendent thinking. What were these networks in the brain, Mary Helen? Describe some of these to me. So there were three main networks involved at the level that we're analyzing. Of course, the brain is infinitely complex.|||And so what we found is that there were particular network properties of the brain that systematically came active and deactive in this coordinated pattern that was driven by the kid's expression of strong emotion and that organized the basic networks in the brain that led to transcendent thinking. What were these networks in the brain, Mary Helen? Describe some of these to me. So there were three main networks involved at the level that we're analyzing. Of course, the brain is infinitely complex.
But these networks were the focus of our investigation. And what we found was that networks that are involved in emotion, in feeling the inside of your guts and visceral body, that tell you when your heart's pounding or that you have a stomach-age, that tell you when there's a snake in your path and suddenly you should and look where you're going, right? Those networks were active. Networks that were allowing the person to sort of focus in a goal-directed way on attending to the world and learning about what was in front of them and remembering it and sort of integrating everything that they'd heard were active early,
But these networks were the focus of our investigation. And what we found was that networks that are involved in emotion, in feeling the inside of your guts and visceral body, that tell you when your heart's pounding or that you have a stomach-age, that tell you when there's a snake in your path and suddenly you should and look where you're going, right? Those networks were active. Networks that were allowing the person to sort of focus in a goal-directed way on attending to the world and learning about what was in front of them and remembering it and sort of integrating everything that they'd heard were active early,|||But these networks were the focus of our investigation. And what we found was that networks that are involved in emotion, in feeling the inside of your guts and visceral body, that tell you when your heart's pounding or that you have a stomach-age, that tell you when there's a snake in your path and suddenly you should and look where you're going, right? Those networks were active. Networks that were allowing the person to sort of focus in a goal-directed way on attending to the world and learning about what was in front of them and remembering it and sort of integrating everything that they'd heard were active early,
but for the first few seconds of watching a story. But then those networks became profoundly deactivated as the kid let go of their attention into the world, and instead networks that are more intrinsically focused, that are mapping your state of consciousness, that are involved in autobiographical memory, that are involved in transcending the current here and now. These are the networks who use to daydream and to mind wander. Those networks became concertedly active as kids were thinking about these big transcendent ideas. So what we showed was that there was a kind of active, dynamic trade-off between outward attention and inward reflection being driven by emotion,
but for the first few seconds of watching a story. But then those networks became profoundly deactivated as the kid let go of their attention into the world, and instead networks that are more intrinsically focused, that are mapping your state of consciousness, that are involved in autobiographical memory, that are involved in transcending the current here and now. These are the networks who use to daydream and to mind wander. Those networks became concertedly active as kids were thinking about these big transcendent ideas. So what we showed was that there was a kind of active, dynamic trade-off between outward attention and inward reflection being driven by emotion,|||but for the first few seconds of watching a story. But then those networks became profoundly deactivated as the kid let go of their attention into the world, and instead networks that are more intrinsically focused, that are mapping your state of consciousness, that are involved in autobiographical memory, that are involved in transcending the current here and now. These are the networks who use to daydream and to mind wander. Those networks became concertedly active as kids were thinking about these big transcendent ideas. So what we showed was that there was a kind of active, dynamic trade-off between outward attention and inward reflection being driven by emotion,
and that sort of seesaw tottering back and forth as the young person was moving themselves into these different modes of brain activity, which are corresponding to different kinds of thinking, that was what we found was associated with this transcendent thinking. You found that transcendent thinking was associated with more resilience in the face of adverse events. How did you discover this? We discovered that most directly with the interviews about the violence and crime that kids had witnessed in their communities. Because what we discovered was that witnessing or even,
and that sort of seesaw tottering back and forth as the young person was moving themselves into these different modes of brain activity, which are corresponding to different kinds of thinking, that was what we found was associated with this transcendent thinking. You found that transcendent thinking was associated with more resilience in the face of adverse events. How did you discover this? We discovered that most directly with the interviews about the violence and crime that kids had witnessed in their communities. Because what we discovered was that witnessing or even,|||and that sort of seesaw tottering back and forth as the young person was moving themselves into these different modes of brain activity, which are corresponding to different kinds of thinking, that was what we found was associated with this transcendent thinking. You found that transcendent thinking was associated with more resilience in the face of adverse events. How did you discover this? We discovered that most directly with the interviews about the violence and crime that kids had witnessed in their communities. Because what we discovered was that witnessing or even,
knowing about crime was associated with thinning in particular regions of the cortex that are involved in kind of outward vigilance, emotion, motivation, learning. Your brain is reacting to the dangerous things around it by becoming hypervigilant and anxious about it. And these were the same regions in the brain that become thinner among soldiers deployed as ground troops. It's also been shown to be involved in post-traumatic stress disorder among people with clinical symptomology. And we were seeing that these very same brain systems were getting thinner in our kids, the more violence they knew about in their community. But what we also found is that the more kids talked in a transcendent way about what could
knowing about crime was associated with thinning in particular regions of the cortex that are involved in kind of outward vigilance, emotion, motivation, learning. Your brain is reacting to the dangerous things around it by becoming hypervigilant and anxious about it. And these were the same regions in the brain that become thinner among soldiers deployed as ground troops. It's also been shown to be involved in post-traumatic stress disorder among people with clinical symptomology. And we were seeing that these very same brain systems were getting thinner in our kids, the more violence they knew about in their community. But what we also found is that the more kids talked in a transcendent way about what could|||knowing about crime was associated with thinning in particular regions of the cortex that are involved in kind of outward vigilance, emotion, motivation, learning. Your brain is reacting to the dangerous things around it by becoming hypervigilant and anxious about it. And these were the same regions in the brain that become thinner among soldiers deployed as ground troops. It's also been shown to be involved in post-traumatic stress disorder among people with clinical symptomology. And we were seeing that these very same brain systems were getting thinner in our kids, the more violence they knew about in their community. But what we also found is that the more kids talked in a transcendent way about what could
be done about the violence, about why it happens. The more they said things like, well, everybody's got a story or a history. You have to look beyond what happened here in this situation and think about, well, how did that person get here, right? And that's where we can do something about making our neighborhood better. When kids said things like that, that kind of thinking physically was associated with thickening in the brain in these same pivotal regions for attention and pain and motivation and learning. And what we found is that thinking in these transcendent ways about the violence actually counteracted the negative effect of violence on the brain development.
be done about the violence, about why it happens. The more they said things like, well, everybody's got a story or a history. You have to look beyond what happened here in this situation and think about, well, how did that person get here, right? And that's where we can do something about making our neighborhood better. When kids said things like that, that kind of thinking physically was associated with thickening in the brain in these same pivotal regions for attention and pain and motivation and learning. And what we found is that thinking in these transcendent ways about the violence actually counteracted the negative effect of violence on the brain development.|||be done about the violence, about why it happens. The more they said things like, well, everybody's got a story or a history. You have to look beyond what happened here in this situation and think about, well, how did that person get here, right? And that's where we can do something about making our neighborhood better. When kids said things like that, that kind of thinking physically was associated with thickening in the brain in these same pivotal regions for attention and pain and motivation and learning. And what we found is that thinking in these transcendent ways about the violence actually counteracted the negative effect of violence on the brain development.
I understand that teenagers who engaged in this kind of transcendent thinking also reported greater life satisfaction to you? So we did a longitudinal study. That means we followed the same group of teenagers for five years, and we kept bringing them back to the lab and then talking to them about who they were and having them tell us about themselves over time. And what we found that was really striking was that their transcendent thinking, the tendency that they brought to the first original interview where they were 14, 15, 16, 17 years old, right, to think about these stories that we were sharing with them in a transcendent way, to move beyond just this is a story about Malala to a story about what's right or good in the world for everyone, right? that tendency in turn predicted the future of the growth of their brain and that growth in turn predicted
I understand that teenagers who engaged in this kind of transcendent thinking also reported greater life satisfaction to you? So we did a longitudinal study. That means we followed the same group of teenagers for five years, and we kept bringing them back to the lab and then talking to them about who they were and having them tell us about themselves over time. And what we found that was really striking was that their transcendent thinking, the tendency that they brought to the first original interview where they were 14, 15, 16, 17 years old, right, to think about these stories that we were sharing with them in a transcendent way, to move beyond just this is a story about Malala to a story about what's right or good in the world for everyone, right? that tendency in turn predicted the future of the growth of their brain and that growth in turn predicted|||I understand that teenagers who engaged in this kind of transcendent thinking also reported greater life satisfaction to you? So we did a longitudinal study. That means we followed the same group of teenagers for five years, and we kept bringing them back to the lab and then talking to them about who they were and having them tell us about themselves over time. And what we found that was really striking was that their transcendent thinking, the tendency that they brought to the first original interview where they were 14, 15, 16, 17 years old, right, to think about these stories that we were sharing with them in a transcendent way, to move beyond just this is a story about Malala to a story about what's right or good in the world for everyone, right? that tendency in turn predicted the future of the growth of their brain and that growth in turn predicted
identity development in late adolescence at age 19 or so right how much kids said yeah I really think about the adult I want to become and what I stand for and what my values are and what I believe in and what my purpose is and in turn identity development at age 19 predicted young adult life satisfaction in their early 20s. Kids' well-being and life-flourishing and satisfaction in their early 20s was predicted by their tendency to engage in more of this transcendent thinking in the original interview five years before. So kids had to show us that across time they were doing the work of growing themselves.
identity development in late adolescence at age 19 or so right how much kids said yeah I really think about the adult I want to become and what I stand for and what my values are and what I believe in and what my purpose is and in turn identity development at age 19 predicted young adult life satisfaction in their early 20s. Kids' well-being and life-flourishing and satisfaction in their early 20s was predicted by their tendency to engage in more of this transcendent thinking in the original interview five years before. So kids had to show us that across time they were doing the work of growing themselves.|||identity development in late adolescence at age 19 or so right how much kids said yeah I really think about the adult I want to become and what I stand for and what my values are and what I believe in and what my purpose is and in turn identity development at age 19 predicted young adult life satisfaction in their early 20s. Kids' well-being and life-flourishing and satisfaction in their early 20s was predicted by their tendency to engage in more of this transcendent thinking in the original interview five years before. So kids had to show us that across time they were doing the work of growing themselves.
So Mary Helen, you've advanced the intriguing theory that transcendent thinking might effectively be the opposite of the patterns of thinking that we often see in anxiety and depression. Can you describe the contrast between these two styles of thinking? What transcendent thinking does that I think is protective for kids and deeply grows them is kids are actively dynamically, agentically. moving themselves from being here and now in the world, paying attention to those around them, reacting appropriately, getting things done, engaging with tasks, and also noticing emotionally when what really matters here is something bigger, when they can withdraw from that
So Mary Helen, you've advanced the intriguing theory that transcendent thinking might effectively be the opposite of the patterns of thinking that we often see in anxiety and depression. Can you describe the contrast between these two styles of thinking? What transcendent thinking does that I think is protective for kids and deeply grows them is kids are actively dynamically, agentically. moving themselves from being here and now in the world, paying attention to those around them, reacting appropriately, getting things done, engaging with tasks, and also noticing emotionally when what really matters here is something bigger, when they can withdraw from that|||So Mary Helen, you've advanced the intriguing theory that transcendent thinking might effectively be the opposite of the patterns of thinking that we often see in anxiety and depression. Can you describe the contrast between these two styles of thinking? What transcendent thinking does that I think is protective for kids and deeply grows them is kids are actively dynamically, agentically. moving themselves from being here and now in the world, paying attention to those around them, reacting appropriately, getting things done, engaging with tasks, and also noticing emotionally when what really matters here is something bigger, when they can withdraw from that
kind of go, go, go, go, do, do, what does it look like, into a place where we think about, what does this mean? And as kids are actively dynamically shifting themselves between those ways of making meaning, they're building the neural muscle, so to speak, for mental health and for good relationships. Others who are engaging in clinical research with teens are showing that these same networks, when they're hyperactive and not flexibly trading off with one another, are involved in what appears to be the neural correlates of these mental illnesses like depression and anxiety. When kids get stuck attending to the outer world and to appearances and worrying about what's around them. We call that anxiety. When they get stuck
有点像前进、前进、前进、去做、去做，这到底是什么样子的，变成了一种让我们思考“这究竟意味着什么？”的境界。当孩子们在这些创造意义的方式之间积极、动态地转换时，他们可以说是在为心理健康和良好的人际关系构建神经肌肉。其他从事青少年临床研究的人员表明，当这些网络处于多动状态且彼此之间无法灵活切换时，它们就参与了这些心理疾病（如抑郁和焦虑）的神经关联表现。当孩子们陷入对外部世界、外表以及对周围事物的担忧中时，我们称之为焦虑。当他们陷入
tipped the other way where they're in their own head and they're thinking about just stories and ruminating, that's associated with depression. What transcendent thinking does is to, is kids are agentically moving themselves between these two states in appropriate ways according to the situation and what it calls for. And that is like a neural muscle that we think produces mental well-being. Mary Helen believes that the development of transcendent thinking should be at the core of every student's education. But of course, it isn't.
另一种极端，即沉浸在自己的脑海中，只想着各种故事并不断反刍时，这就与抑郁有关。超越性思维的作用在于，孩子们根据情况和实际需求，以恰当的方式在自主地在这两种状态之间转换。这就像是一块我们认为能带来心理健康的神经肌肉。玛丽·海伦认为，培养超越性思维应该成为每个学生教育的核心。但当然，目前并非如此。
So many students around the world experience school today as deathly boring. When we come back, how to place engagement at the center of education. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Mary Helen Imordino-Yang is a psychologist and neuroscientist at the University of Southern California. She's the author of Emotions, Learning, and The Brain, Exploring the Educational Implications of Affective Neuroscience. Mary Helen, you've been studying expert teachers to determine what they know about how adolescents develop and thrive.
世界上许多学生今天都觉得学校无聊至极。休息之后，我们将探讨如何将参与感置于教育的核心。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹坦。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹坦。玛丽·海伦·伊莫迪诺-杨是南加州大学的心理学家和神经科学家。她是《情感、学习与大脑：探索情感神经科学对教育的启示》一书的作者。玛丽·海伦，你一直在研究优秀教师，以了解他们对青少年如何发展和茁壮成长的认知。
In some ways, you're looking at examples of what social scientists might call positive deviance, you know, the math teacher who gets students to not just be proficient in math, but to actually love math. and I understand you're examining what these teachers are doing in their classrooms. Yeah, that's right. We set out to study teachers working in urban inner city Los Angeles whose administrators identified them as their quote-unquote superstars, right? The teachers who kids really love, really go to, the teachers who the administrators say are just the ones really dedicated to the kids
从某种意义上说，你正在研究社会科学家所说的“积极越轨”的例子，你知道的，比如那个不仅能让学生精通数学、而且能让他们真正热爱数学的数学老师。据我所知，你正在考察这些老师在课堂上的做法。是的，没错。我们着手研究了洛杉矶市中心内城区的教师，他们的管理者将其确定为所谓的超级巨星，对吧？也就是孩子们真正热爱、真正愿意去找的老师，管理者口中那些真正对孩子们全心全意奉献的老师。
who do really great work. And so we approached 40 of these. amazing people and asked them if they would be willing to let us study them, basically to have us videotape them in their classroom and whether they would come to the lab and actually let us image their brains in real time while they did their work. They graded their students' homeworks and gave feedback to their students and made judgments about classroom activities that they saw and told us what they thought about them. What we found was quite extraordinary. So we gave them a kid's assignment. We said, this is Shankar's work, grade his
他们做着非常棒的工作。因此，我们接触了其中 40 位了不起的人，询问他们是否愿意让我们研究他们，基本上就是允许我们在他们的课堂上进行录像，以及他们是否愿意来到实验室，在他们开展日常工作时实时成像他们的大脑。他们批改学生的作业，给学生反馈，对看到的课堂活动做出判断，并告诉我们他们对此的想法。我们的发现非常非同寻常。因此，我们给了他们一份孩子的作业。我们说，这是香卡的作业，批改一下他的
assignment. And then, you know, here's Mary Helen's work, grade her assignment. And then, after a bunch of their own kids, we gave them a bunch of kids' assignments that we told them were not their own kids' work. And we told them we had taken those off the internet. And actually what we had done, though, is written those assignments to be matched in quality. And what we found was that first, the teachers graded the two assignments the same way. So, you know, gave Mary Helen a B over here, and you gave the fake answer that we pulled off the internet from a kid that things like Mary Helen also a B, right? So they knew what they were doing.
作业。然后，你知道的，这是玛丽·海伦的作业，批改她的作业。接着，在处理完他们自己学生的一批作业后，我们给他们发了一批其他孩子的作业，我们告诉他们这不是他们自己学生的作业。我们告诉他们这些是从网上找来的。但实际上，我们所做的是编写了那些在质量上相匹配的作业。我们发现，首先，老师们对这两份作业的批改方式是一样的。所以，你知道的，在这里给玛丽·海伦一个B，而对于我们从网上找来的、假装是某个孩子的答案，你也给玛丽·海伦一个B，对吧？所以他们知道自己在做什么。
But what we found was that the brain activity, when they graded their own students versus students they didn't know, was massively more. All over the brain, we see increases in activity in regions involved in motivation, attention, memory, emotion, autobiographical thinking, ideas, beliefs, consciousness, right? These teachers are doing more mental, social, affective work when they're seeing their own kids' assignments than when they're seeing the assignments that are the same, but by kids they don't know. What that tells us is that excellent teachers are doing work that is deeply social and
但我们发现，当他们批改自己学生的作业与不认识的学生的作业时，大脑活动有天壤之别。在整个大脑中，我们看到参与动机、注意力、记忆、情感、自传体思维、观点、信念、意识的区域活动都在增加，对吧？当这些老师看到自己孩子的作业时，比看到由他们不认识的孩子所做的同样作业时，他们正在进行更多的大脑、社交、情感层面的工作。这告诉我们，优秀的教师所做的工作具有深刻的社交性、
and emotional and effortful, even beyond what's required to just accomplish the teaching task, which is grading the assignment. So what was accounting for the difference in the brain, activity, in the two conditions? We asked these same teachers to provide open-ended feedback to their students. And so we said, here's your student, Mary Helen. What would you say to Mary Helen if you had a meeting with her about how she's doing? Here's your student, Shankar. What would you say to Shankar if you had a meeting with him about who he's doing?
情感性且需要付出努力，甚至超出了完成教学任务（即批改作业）本身的要求。那么，是什么导致了这两种情况下大脑活动的差异呢？我们要求这些相同的老师给他们的学生提供开放式的反馈。于是我们说，这是你的学生玛丽·海伦。如果你要与她开会讨论她的表现，你会对玛丽·海伦说些什么？这是你的学生香卡。如果你要与他开会讨论他的表现，你会对香卡说些什么？
And what we were looking for was to what degree do teachers actually appreciate and support actively in their feedback to their students the whole development of that young person's capacities of mind? And what we found was that the more a teacher's feedback to their students involve this kind of deep developmental support. the more activity they showed when they saw their real students' assignments versus kids' assignments that they don't know the kid. Truly great teachers do more than convey information. In fact, they do more than help students think. They attend to where their students are emotionally, developmentally. The great teacher is asking,
我们寻找的是，在多大程度上，教师在给学生的反馈中真正欣赏并积极支持那个年轻人思维能力的全面发展。我们发现，老师对学生的反馈越是涉及这种深度的发展支持，当他们看到真实学生的作业与不认识的学生的作业时，他们表现出的脑活动就越多。真正伟大的老师不仅仅是传达信息。事实上，他们做的不仅仅是帮助学生思考。他们关注学生在情感上、发展上的处境。伟大的老师会问：
where is the student in their development as a human being? How can I support that growth? Mary Helen says that neuroscience shows that this question cannot be purely about intellect. It has to be about emotion as well. I think our traditional Western philosophies too often separate cognition and emotion. We think that there are cognitive skills and there are emotional skills, right? And that maybe those two things impact on each other, right? But actually, that's the wrong way to think about it.
作为一个人，这个学生正处于发展的什么阶段？我该如何支持这种成长？玛丽·海伦表示，神经科学表明，这个问题绝不能仅仅关乎智力。它也必须关乎情感。我认为我们传统的西方哲学往往将认知和情感割裂开来。我们认为有认知技能，也有情感技能，对吧？并且这两者可能会相互影响，对吧？但实际上，这种想法是错误的。
There are two different dimensions of the same thing. Thinking is inherently cognitive and emotional always at the same time. And we can look at thinking from a cognitive lens and analyze the cognitive dimensions of what's going on, and it's important to do that. We can look at thinking from an effective lens and analyze the emotional engagement that's going on. But actually, both of those things are simultaneously happening in an integrated way, always, when people are alive, when they're moving through the world, adapting and engaging with the things around them. Great teachers understand, perhaps instinctively, that in order to get students to learn, they have to care about what they are learning. Emotion has to sit in the driver's seat, if you will. This is not merely an argument about how school ought to work.
它们是同一事物的两个不同维度。思考本质上既是认知的，又总是同时充满情感的。我们可以从认知镜头来看待思考，分析其中进行的认知维度，这样做很重要。我们可以从情感镜头来看待思考，分析正在进行的情感投入。但实际上，当人们活着、在世界中穿梭、适应并与周围事物互动时，这两件事总是同时以一种综合的方式发生着。伟大的老师或许凭借本能理解，为了让学生学习，他们必须关心自己正在学习的内容。可以说，情感必须坐在驾驶座上。这不仅仅是一个关于学校应该如何运作的论点。
Mary Helen says this is simply how the human brain is designed to work. Yeah, it turns out biology doesn't waste energy, right? We don't think about things that don't matter because that would be a waste of time and energy. So if you think about it this way, whatever you're having emotion about is what you're thinking about. And whatever you're thinking about, you might be able to learn about. about. So we need to ask ourselves as parents, as teachers, as people, what am I having emotion about? And when the emotions of school and development are about the achievements and the outcomes and the results, that is what you have a hope of learning about. When the emotions in school are
玛丽·海伦说，这只是人类大脑被设计成的工作方式而已。是的，事实证明生物不会浪费能量，对吧？我们不会去思考无关紧要的事情，因为那会浪费时间和精力。所以如果你这样想，无论你对什么产生情感，那就是你在思考的事情。而无论你在思考什么，你都可能去了解它。因此，作为父母、作为老师、作为个体，我们需要问自己：我对什么产生了情感？当学校和发展的感情是关于成就、成果和结果时，这正是你有望去了解的。当学校的情感是
about the physics, why the ball is rolling down the ramp and this hidden idea that there's this force you can't see that's pulling on the ball and it's also pulling on us and it's making the moon make the tides, right? When the emotion is about that powerful idea, that is one meaningful learning is about the idea. And that's when you actually build transferable knowledge that is developmentally changing the person for having learned it. You saw how this worked for one student in particular who was able to attach emotion and meaning to a philosophical problem that's known as Zeno's paradox. The paradox goes back, you know, many centuries.
关于物理学，比如为什么球会沿着斜坡滚下来，以及这个隐藏的概念：有一种你看不见的力在拉着这个球，它也在拉着我们，它让月亮形成了潮汐，对吧？当情感与那个强大的想法有关时，这才是真正的有意义的学习关乎这个想法。正是在这个时候，你实际上建立可迁移的知识，这些知识因学习过它而在发展上改变着这个人。你看到了这对于特定的一位学生是如何奏效的，他能够将情感和意义附加到一个被称为“芝诺悖论”的哲学问题上。这个悖论可以追溯到，你知道的，许多世纪以前。
Imagine you're running a 100-meter race. You first have to run 50 meters, in other words, half the distance. And then you have to run 25 meters, or in other words, half the remaining distance. And of course, you can keep doing this, which is each time you're running half of the remaining distance. And the paradox is that since there are an infinite number of half distances that you have to traverse, you will never reach the 100-meter finish line, whereas, of course, we know that in the real world,
假设你正在进行一场 100 米赛跑。你首先必须跑完 50 米，换句话说，也就是一半的距离。然后你必须跑完 25 米，换句话说，也就是剩余距离的一半。当然，你可以一直这样下去，每一次你跑的都是剩余距离的一半。而这个悖论在于，既然你需要穿过无限多个一半的距离，你就永远无法到达 100 米的终点线，然而，当然，我们知道在现实世界中，
we all routinely can run the 100-meter. So this is the paradox known as Xenos paradox. Tell me the story of what happened and how the student attached emotion and meaning to the paradox and came to understand it in the context of his own life. So this is an example of a really fantastic math curriculum that's built by a school in New York City that's an alternative high school for kids who haven't passed their classes in traditional schools
我们大家都能很常规地跑完这 100 米。这就是被称为芝诺悖论的悖论。请告诉我发生了什么故事，以及这个学生是如何将情感和意义赋予这个悖论，并在他自己的生活背景下去理解它的。所以这是一个非常棒的数学课程的例子，由纽约市的一所学校建立，这是一所针对在传统学校中未能及格的孩子的替代性高中，
for whatever reason. Some of them are new immigrants to the country. Some of them have just failed in the past and not connected with school. Some of them are in trouble. And so these teachers have designed a math curriculum that turns things on its head, right? But they actually have it right. Rather than starting with the building blocks of how to calculate things and working up. They start with big, powerful, intriguing ideas. They get kids involved with those. They choose big problems to work on. And then those problems become the space in which they learn mathematical calculation because they're so driven to understand their problem. So this one young man is describing how he had never before taken a math class and passed. And in this math
无论出于什么原因。其中一些是该国的新移民。其中一些过去曾挂科、没有融入学校。其中一些遇到了麻烦。因此，这些老师设计了一种颠覆常规的数学课程，对吧？但他们的做法其实是正确的。他们不是从如何计算的基础知识开始并向上攀升。而是从宏大、强大、引人入胜的想法开始。他们让孩子们参与其中。他们选择重大的问题来研究。然后这些问题就成了他们学习数学计算的空间，因为他们极度渴望理解自己的问题。因此，这个年轻人描述了他以前从未上过及格的数学课。而在这次数学
class, he was given a big problem called Xenos Paradox. It's this problem that he calls walking to the door. You get halfway, halfway, halfway to the door. Do you ever make it to the door? Why or why not? And he says, I got so fascinated by this problem. I had to learn fractions to solve the problem I had. And I got fascinated by ideas like asymptotes and finite and infinite. And he talks about how he's moving back and forth between being fascinated by this big idea and having to learn the calculations and the mathematical concepts to be able to satisfy his curiosity about that big idea. And as we think tilting his brains are back and forth from paying attention, learning about
课上，他得到了一个名为“芝诺悖论”的宏大问题。这就是他所说的“走到门前”的问题。你走到了一半、一半、又一半。你真的能走到门前吗？为什么能或为什么不能？他说，我被这个问题深深迷住了。为了解决我遇到的问题，我不得不去学习分数。我被渐近线、有限和无限等概念迷住了。他谈到自己如何在被这个宏大想法迷住、以及为了满足自己对这个宏大想法的好奇心而不得不学习计算和数学概念之间来回穿梭。当我们思考时，我们的大脑在集中注意力、学习
fractions because I care about big ideas like infinity. What an amazing idea. An asymptote that you get closer and closer to something, but you never reach it, right? As he's doing that, he's tickling up, we think, the same regions of his brain that are the ones that are the kind of pivot of the attentional seesaw,
分数来回摆动，因为我在意像无穷大这样宏大的想法。多么奇妙的想法！渐近线，你越来越接近某个东西，但你永远无法触及它，对吧？当他这样做时，我们认为，他正在激活大脑中相同的区域，这些区域就像是注意力跷跷板的支点，
which are the feeling of your guts and viscera and your own self. And what we think is happening is that by engaging in these agentic ways of moving yourself between doing the skill and thinking about the big idea and then doing the calculations again because you care about the big idea,
也就是你肠道、内脏以及自我感受的区域。我们认为发生的情况是，通过以这些自主的方式在做技能和思考宏大想法之间转换自己，然后因为你关心宏大想法而再次进行计算，
is that the after effect is you activate up these regions of the brain that are the seat of our subjective feeling of our own internal self. They're the feeling of being me. And the kid says, and many of the kids in this kind of curriculum say, it got relevant to my life, it mattered to my life. You've never passed a math class before. You're a new immigrant to the United States. United States, living in poverty, and infinity got relevant to your life and fractions? Because relevance is not necessarily simply about the direct applicability of a skill to your everyday things you need to accomplish. That's important, but that's relevance with what I
其后效是你激活了大脑的这些区域，这些区域是我们对内部自我的主观感受的发源地。它们是“成为我”的感觉。那个孩子说，并且这种课程中的许多孩子都说，它与我的生活相关了，它对我的生活很重要。你以前从未及格过数学课。你是美国的新移民，
would call a little R. Relevance with a big R is it feels like me to think about and understand this big, powerful idea. I'm moving through the world with a level of understanding and analysis that I didn't have before, that feels powerful. And when you do that, the math becomes relevant to who I am. There is a philosophical shift in thinking that lies at the heart of engaging people in exploration and curiosity. It involves paying less attention to what you are teaching, whether that's algebra or civics, and more attention to the development of the human being you are trying to teach. Mary Helen calls this conceptual shift the equivalent of a Copernican revolution.
生活在贫困之中，而无穷大和分数竟然与你的生活相关了？因为相关性不一定仅仅关乎一项技能与你需要完成的日常事务之间的直接适用性。这很重要，但那是小“r”的相关性。大“r”的相关性是指，思考和理解这个宏大、强大的想法让我觉得自己就是我。我在以一种我以前没有的理解和分析水平在世界中穿梭，这感觉很有力量。当你这样做时，数学就与我是谁产生了关联。在让人们参与探索和好奇心的核心，存在着一种思维上的哲学转变。它涉及减少对你正在教的内容（无论是代数还是公民课）的关注，而更多地关注你试图教的人类的发展。玛丽·海伦称这种概念上的转变为哥白尼式革命的等同物。
So we set the cart before the horse in the way we design our curricula right now. We're thinking too much about what little learning nuggets get shoved in the cart, and we forget to think about who's the horse pulling that cart. What does that horse need? And that's, I think, the fundamental problem with the way we've, designed our education system today. That's coming up next. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
所以我们在目前设计课程的方式中，有点本末倒置了。我们过多地考虑将什么样的小学习碎片塞进推车里，却忘了去思考拉车的马是谁。那匹马需要什么？我认为，这就是我们今天设计教育系统方式的根本问题。接下来即将播出。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedant. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. Mary Helen Imordino-Yang found herself deeply disengaged when she was in school. After she became an education researcher and a parent herself, the wheel came full circle. She told me a story about her own son. The story comes in two chapters, second grade and third grade. In second grade, he was so disheartened with him. with school because he finally expressed to me that they don't study the things in school that
我是香卡·韦丹坦。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹坦。玛丽·海伦·伊莫迪诺-杨发现在上学时自己非常缺乏参与感。在她成为一名教育研究人员并成为母亲之后，一切又回到了起点。她给我讲了一个关于她自己儿子的故事。这个故事分为两个章节，二年级和三年级。在二年级时，他对
he was interested in. And I said, well, what are you interested in? He said, well, airplanes and how they work. I said, okay, here's what you should do, Ted. You write a letter to your teacher and you explain and write a proposal in which you say, how about, right, like I was able to study airplanes and other kids might be able to study other things that they're interested in. And you work out how this will happen, right? And so he wrote a whole proposal to his teachers that basically said, how about if every kid had the chance and the option to engage in an extra project where they could investigate on their own and explore it, they could get approval first for the topic and some guidance from their teacher, and then they could go off and study something they're
学校感到非常沮丧，因为他终于向我表达，他们在学校里学的东西并不是他感兴趣的。我说，好吧，那你对什么感兴趣？他说，嗯，飞机以及它们是如何工作的。我说，好吧，泰德，你应该这样做。你给你的老师写一封信，解释并写一份提案，在其中说，怎么样，就像我可以研究飞机，其他孩子也可以研究他们感兴趣的其他东西。然后你算出这该如何实现，对吧？于是他给老师写了一份完整的提案，基本上是说，如果每个孩子都有机会和选择参与一个额外的项目，他们可以自己去调查和探索，他们可以首先获得老师对主题的批准和一些指导，然后他们就可以去研究自己
interested in, and when they're ready, they could come back and they could report on that to the class. And so his teacher said, fantastic, you're welcome to do that. So he went off and began studying about airplane wings and their aerodynamic properties and all these things with my husband, his father, who is an aerospace engineer. And he came back and did this amazing presentation that my husband had helped him design and they did together where they taught the class about how airplane wings work and the ways that lift operates and all these kinds of things. And he had an amazing time. The following year, he had a teacher who was very good, but she didn't understand that the purpose of school was to engage kids.
感兴趣的东西，当他们准备好时，他们可以回来向全班汇报。于是他的老师说，太棒了，欢迎你这么做。于是他出发了，开始和我丈夫（他的父亲，是一名航空航天工程师）一起研究飞机机翼及其空气动力学特性以及所有这些东西。他回来做了一个精彩的展示，那是我丈夫帮他设计并他们一起完成的，他们在那里向全班教授飞机机翼是如何工作的、升力是如何运作的以及所有这些种类的东西。他度过了一段美妙的时光。第二年，他遇到了一位很好的老师，但她并不明白学校的目的是让孩子们
deeply with ideas. She thought of the kids and her as partners in the learning process that she was giving them the information and their job was to, you know, sort of compliantly give back. And when that happened well, and according to plan, that's the definition of a good student. And Ted was deeply disheartened by this approach. And it came out in his real dislike and failure to move on from thinking about this behavior chart that she had in the class, which was not in any of his other classes in the school, where she had, you know, kind of green on the top, you're doing what you're supposed to do, yellow in the middle, like you're getting in hot water, and red meaning like, you know, you're behaving badly, right? And kids' little clips were moving up and down
深入参与到思想中去。她认为孩子们和她是学习过程中的伙伴，她提供信息，而他们的工作是，你知道的，顺从地反馈回去。当这一切进展顺利且按计划进行时，这就是一个好学生的定义。而泰德对这种方法感到非常沮丧。这表现在他极度不喜欢并且无法不去想她在班上使用的那个行为图表，这在学校的其他任何班级里都没有，她在那上面，你知道的，顶部是绿色，表示你在做你该做的事，中间是黄色，就像你遇到了麻烦，红色意味着，你知道的，你表现不好，对吧？孩子们的小夹子在上面上下移动
on this. And he finally was so upset about it. And she didn't understand how, if he was always on green, it was a problem. And what he wrote to her in a little. letter, finally, was that it's like when I get to school every day, he says, I think it's a new day, and I get there to try to learn something new and exciting, and instead I see the dot, dot, dot, bad behavior chart, right? And he says, this fact makes me very uncomfortable. And he goes on to explain how it's as if the teacher is trying to dare me to do something bad. It's like, what he's really saying is, I thought school was about ideas and learning, and you're telling it's about compliance and behavior.
在这个图表上。他最终为此感到非常沮丧。而她不明白为什么如果他一直保持在绿色也是个问题。最终，他在一封小信中写给她的内容是，这就好像我每天到学校时，他说，我认为这是一个新的一天，我来到这里是为了学习一些新的、令人兴奋的东西，而我看到的却是那个点、点、点、不良行为图表，对吧？他说，这个事实让我感到很不舒服。接着他解释说，这就像老师在试图激怒我做坏事一样。这就像，他真正想说的是，我以为学校是关于思想和学习的，而你却在告诉我它是关于顺从和行为的。
What Mary Helen and her colleagues have found is that the best teachers engage the kind of transcendent thinking that we discussed earlier. Regardless of whether they are teaching chemistry or civics, history or math, they are constantly asking themselves, how can I help my students see the big ideas behind the facts I'm teaching? Mary Helen cites the example of two teachers she tracked during one of her studies.
玛丽·海伦和她的同事们发现，最好的老师会激发我们之前讨论过的那种超越性思维。无论他们教的是化学还是公民学、历史还是数学，他们都在不断地问自己：我该如何帮助我的学生看到我所教的事实背后的宏大思想？玛丽·海伦列举了她在其中一项研究中追踪过的两位老师的例子。
Both are gifted, but one of them is focused on skillfully transmitting information and the other is focused on growing the brains of students using the syllabus as a launch pad for transcendent thinking. We had one teacher who invited us to see the class that he had designed as a review for his civics class, high school civics class, the review before the final exam. It was before the winter holiday. He had a holiday playlist playing of music in the background. He had made a game where he put up on the board questions with multiple choice and kids were in teams with whiteboards and they had to write down what they thought their answer was
两人都很有天赋，但其中一位专注于熟练地传授信息，而另一位则专注于利用教学大纲作为超越性思维的发射台来发展学生的大脑。我们有一位老师邀请我们去参观他为公民课（高中公民课）期末考试前的复习课所设计的班级。那是寒假之前。他背景音乐里放着节日播放列表。他制作了一个游戏，把带有选择题的问题写在黑板上，孩子们分成小组，拿着小白板，他们必须写下他们认为的答案是什么，
and it was timed. And he was dancing with a lightsaber to entertain them and keep them moving. And the kids were all saying, what do you think it is? What's the answer? I think it's a, I think it's B. And then he would say, everybody put their whiteboards up and like the answer's B and you and get me the points and they would put the points on the board, right? Contrast that with a teacher who was teaching algebra two. And what she had done around her class was explained to kids that the ways
并且是计时答题。他挥舞着光剑跳舞来娱乐他们，让他们保持活力。孩子们都在说，你觉得是什么？答案是什么？我觉得是A，我觉得是B。然后他会说，大家把小白板举起来，比如答案是B，然后你给我加分，他们会把分数记在黑板上，对吧？与此形成鲜明对比的是一位教代数二的老师。她在课堂周围对孩子们做的事情是解释
that exponential functions work, the ways that quadratic equations work, they allow you to calculate something called exponential growth. And what she did was as the kids were learning the math, she then assigned them to families from the neighborhood as financial planners. So they worked and wrestled with those families across the semester to get financial information about those families' hopes, to buy a home, to pay for their kids' education, those kinds of things, their income, their expenses. And the kids used their algebra two skills to calculate the cost of owning a home, the amount they should be saving to be able to pay for their child's education someday.
指数函数是如何运作的，二次方程是如何运作的，它们允许你计算一种叫做指数增长的东西。而她所做的是，当孩子们在学习数学时，她随后将他们作为理财规划师分配给社区的家庭。因此，他们在整个学期中与这些家庭一起工作和切磋，以获取这些家庭关于买房、支付孩子教育费用等愿望的财务信息，还有他们的收入、支出。孩子们用他们的代数二技能来计算拥有房屋的成本，以及为了能够支付孩子未来教育费用而应该节省的金额。
And they worked with real families and presented them with financial planning resources. As those kids engaged in that math, they were so deeply connected to the reason why that math matters. It empowered them to be useful members of their community, to be experts who were resources to the families in their community. And, of course, at this point, the formulas for compound interest are only a means to the end. And the end is, how do I help this other family, make sure that they are planning securely for the future? Yes, that's right. And at the same time, I'm actually really deeply invested in learning my math. What often happens, I spend a lot of time talking to teachers and parents and kids.
他们与真正的家庭合作，并向他们提供财务规划资源。当这些孩子们参与到那个数学中时，他们与该数学之所以重要的原因产生了极其深刻的联系。这使他们有能力成为社区中有用的成员，成为可以为社区家庭提供资源的专家。当然，在这一点上，复利公式只是一种达到目的的手段。而目的是：我如何帮助这个其他家庭，确保他们为未来做出安全的财务规划？是的，没错。与此同时，我实际上非常深入地投入到学习我的数学中。经常发生的情况是，我花了很多时间与老师、家长和孩子交流。
What often happens is that when teachers learn about this, they say, they first see the person with the whiteboard and the civics game and he thinks, oh, look at those kids, are super engaged. Those aren't the kind of kids who normally would be engaged in this. They're all answering the questions and stuff. and they think that's great. And then you start to show them other examples of teachers like the algebra two teacher or others where the kids are calm, they're thoughtful, and they're assured, and they act professional.
经常发生的情况是，当老师们了解到这一点时，他们会说，他们首先看到的是那个拿着小白板和公民课游戏的人，他想，哦，看那些孩子，超级投入。那些通常不会参与这种活动的孩子。他们都在回答问题之类的。并且他们觉得这很棒。然后你开始向他们展示其他老师的例子，比如代数二老师或其他老师，那里的孩子们很冷静、深思熟虑、自信，而且举止专业。
They are advising a family on their financial planning and the demeanor they bring to their math, all of a sudden the teachers perk up and say, oh, I guess I knew that. Of course. I've always wanted to do that, but I didn't know how. I knew I was noticing disengagement in my kids, But I thought that the opposite of disengagement was entertainment.
他们在就财务规划向一个家庭提供建议，以及他们在数学中表现出的风度，突然之间老师们振作起来说，哦，我想我知道了。当然。我一直想这么做，但我不知道怎么做。我知道我注意到我的孩子缺乏参与感，但我以为缺乏参与感的反面是娱乐。
And everybody putting their hand up and saying, oh, call on me. This is fun. I love school, which is great. That's not terrible. But it's not enough. Deep engagement, it looks calm. It looks thoughtful. It looks agentic.
每个人都举手说，哦，点我。这很有趣。我爱学校，这很好。这并不糟糕。但这还不够。深度参与，它看起来很平静。它看起来深思熟虑。它看起来很自主。
It looks like kids are actually interested in what they're studying. They understand why they're doing it and they're deeply invested in what they're doing. I mean, in some ways, I think what I hear you saying is that this algebra two teacher is actually not so much teaching algebra two as much as a form of human development. Well, she's teaching algebra two as a means to human development, right? In education, we've made the mistake of thinking that the quote-unquote outcome of school is quote-unquote learning, right? Learning outcomes are how we measure whether school was successful. But I would argue that learning outcomes are a misnomer. There are red herring. Those are incredibly important things
它看起来像是孩子们真的对他们正在学习的东西感兴趣。他们明白他们为什么要这样做，并且他们深深地投入到他们正在做的事情中。我的意思是，从某种程度上说，我认为我听到你所说的是，这位代数二老师其实与其说是在教代数二，不如说是在教一种人类发展的形式。嗯，她是在把代数二作为促进人类发展的手段来教，对吧？在教育中，我们犯了一个错误，认为学校的所谓成果就是所谓的学习，对吧？学习成果是我们衡量学校是否成功的方式。但我要辩称，学习成果是一个用词不当的说法。它们是红鲱鱼。那些是极其重要的事情
to achieve. You must learn things in school. But that's not the ultimate purpose of school. That's the means to the ultimate purpose. The ultimate purpose, the outcome is human development. So we have to ask ourselves, what does having learned this enable in the kids as they move forward? How does having been here and experienced this learning opportunity change who they are developmentally moving forward? How does it change their proclivities? to engage with information, their dispositions to think about complex information in this field. Has it changed the way they understand and think scientifically, who they position themselves to be when they move through the world? And that is meaningful, developmentally oriented education.
去实现。你必须在学校里学习东西。但那并不是学校的终极目的。那是达到终极目的的手段。终极目的、成果是人类发展。所以我们必须问自己，拥有这些学习成果能让孩子们在前进的过程中具备什么能力？身处此地并经历这个学习机会如何改变了他们作为发展中的个体不断前进的身份？它如何改变他们参与信息的倾向，他们以这种领域中思考复杂信息的性格？它是否改变了他们理解和思考科学的方式，他们在世界中穿梭时将自己定位为什么样的人？这就是有意义的、以发展为导向的教育。
The learning is important. It's critical, but it is not the endpoint. It's the end point. It's the means. The endpoint is the development, and we've neglected that. I'm wondering if one implication of this, Mary Helen, is that in some ways, the range and volume of things that we typically expect students to learn in high school or college might be too much. And in some ways, if you want to get really deep engagement and really want people to go deep rather than broad, you might actually have to cover less ground than we're covering today. Yeah, I think that's partly true. But I also think that once kids develop a real disposition to learn, once they develop a curiosity and a way of approaching the academic opportunities you provide for them, that really puts the agency in their pocket rather than in the adults, what happens is kids can accomplish super things. But what's true is that when we overly constrain and make them learn a broad range of things without. the opportunities to really go deep, what happens is that all of the learning becomes superficial
学习很重要。它是至关重要的，但它不是终点。它是终点。它是手段。终点是发展，而我们忽视了这一点。我想知道玛丽·海伦，这是否意味着从某种程度上说，我们通常期望学生在高中或大学学习的事物的范围和数量可能太多了？在某种程度上，如果你想获得真正深度的参与，并且真正希望人们走得深而不是广，你实际上可能不得不比我们今天涵盖的范围更少。是的，我认为这部分是真的。但我也认为，一旦孩子们养成了真正的学习倾向，一旦他们培养了好奇心以及一种对待你为他们提供的学术机会的方式，这真正把主动权掌握在他们自己手里而不是大人手里，发生的情况是孩子们可以完成超凡的事情。但事实是，当我们过度约束他们并让他们学习广泛的东西，却没有
and it ends up not sticking with them anyway. What's really key for young people to develop is the disposition to deeply engage with learning and the self-awareness in the learning process to know what it feels like to really understand something, what it feels like to become an expert. You know, one way I explain this is when we look at little kids, you know, lots of us have been or had four-year-olds who got super fascinated with dinosaurs, right? They started memorizing all the names of the dinosaurs and what they ate and what kind of teeth they had and all this kind of stuff. And, you know, no one stops and says, oh, my four-year-old is really on track to becoming a paleontologist, right? What is it that they're doing? They're developing their proclivity for
真正深入的机会时，发生的情况是所有的学习都变得表面化了，而且最终无论如何也无法在他们脑海中留下深刻印象。对年轻人来说真正关键的发展是：深入参与学习的倾向，以及在学习过程中了解真正理解某事是什么感觉、成为专家是什么感觉的自我觉察。你知道，我解释这一点的一种方式是，当我们看小孩子时，你知道，我们很多人都曾经是或者拥有过对恐龙超级着迷的四岁小孩，对吧？他们开始背诵所有恐龙的名字、它们吃什么、它们有什么样的牙齿以及所有这类东西。而且，你知道的，没有人会停下来然后说，哦，我的四岁小孩真的走上了成为古生物学家的正轨，对吧？他们在做什么？他们在培养他们的
learning. They're experiencing a little bit of expertise. They may probably even know more about something than their parent does? How empowering is that? And they're searching out new learning about something that isn't in their immediate here and now that they have to go to museums or books to learn about. And that's the developmental nature of that learning process. But when our kids get to be teenagers, we somehow think that the learning is mainly about stashing little nuts in their head like a squirrel, right? Where it's about how many little things can you shove in there? And we forget that the point is just like with those four-year-olds, the content is important. You need a breadth of content, right, and ways of thinking about things.
学习倾向。他们正在体验一点点专业知识。他们甚至可能比他们的父母对某事知道得更多？这有多么赋能！而且他们正在寻找关于不在他们眼前即时时空中的新学习，他们必须去博物馆或书籍中了解这些。这就是那个学习过程的发展性质。但当我们的孩子变成青少年时，我们不知何故认为学习主要是像松鼠一样把小坚果藏在他们的脑袋里，对吧？在那里，它是关于你能把多少小东西塞进去？而且我们忘记了重点就像那些四岁小孩一样，内容很重要。你需要内容的广度，对吧，以及思考事物的方式。
But what's really important is that you learn proclivities for deeply engaging with expertise, with ideas, with evidence, with thoughtful ways of analyzing and understanding things. But we often, in mainstream, secondary education, do not do this. We substitute content for developmental. opportunities to learn to think. I'm wondering whether people give you pushback and say, you know, Mary Helen, what you're describing is very idealistic and would be wonderful to do in classrooms and schools.
但真正重要的是，你培养出深度参与专业知识、思想、证据、分析和理解事物的深思熟虑方式的倾向。但在主流中等教育中，我们往往不这样做。我们用内容来代替学习思考的发展机会。我想知道是否有人会反驳你说，你知道，玛丽·海伦，你所描述的非常理想主义，在教室和学校里做会很棒。
But the challenges that we're facing are at a much more basic level. You know, students are not showing up to class. We have attendance problems. We have discipline problems. Is your recommendation, Mary Helen, something that is actually practical? Yeah, well, I got news. Like, the wide real world isn't working very well for a lot of kids, right? And so we keep doubling down on starting with the basics and working our way up and the kids are absent, right, either mentally or heaven forbid physically, right?
但我们面临的挑战是在一个更基础的层面。你知道，学生没有来上课。我们有出勤问题。我们有纪律问题。玛丽·海伦，你的建议实际上是切合实际的吗？是的，好吧，我有消息要告诉你。就像，广阔的现实世界对许多孩子来说并不奏效，对吧？所以我们一直在加倍努力从基础开始并向上攀升，而孩子们却缺席了，对吧，无论是在精神上还是上帝保佑在身体上，对吧？
That's because the design of our education system does not align with the developmental needs of young people. Human beings show up naturally with curiosity, with adaptability, with engagement. and when we lower their engagement and curiosity to tiny little building block things that you have to pass through those bottlenecks before you can get to anything interesting, you have lost them. What if we turned it around and we invite kids back to school with big ideas, with powerful projects, with opportunities to actually make change in their community, start there and work backwards to the instrumental skills, the history, the right, writing, you know, the interviewing, the speaking, all of the skills that would play into their ability to do those projects. We have to put the big idea first. So you engage kids and give them the power to need school. And then you say, okay, you need to know fractions. Kid who's excited about Zeno's paradox. Step back. Come over here. I'm going to teach it to you. Now you need
那是因为我们的教育系统设计不符合年轻人的发展需求。人类自然地带着好奇心、适应性、参与度出现。当我们把他们的参与度和好奇心降到那些微小的基石事情上，在你能接触到任何有趣的东西之前你必须通过那些瓶颈，你就已经失去了他们。如果我们扭转局面，用宏大的想法、强大的项目、真正为社区带来改变的机会把孩子们重新请回学校，从那里开始并倒推到工具性技能、历史、写作、采访、演讲，所有这些能够发挥他们完成这些项目能力技能。我们必须把宏大思想放在首位。所以你吸引孩子们并赋予他们需要学校的力量。然后你说，好吧，你需要了解分数。对芝诺悖论感到兴奋的孩子。往后退。过来这里。我要教给你。现在你需要
to know it, right? You're studying about lead in the water in Flint, Michigan. let me teach you some chemistry. It's going to be very useful to you trying to figure out that thing you're really deeply engaged in, right? So we set the cart before the horse in the way we design our curricula right now. We're thinking too much about
了解它了，对吧？你正在研究密歇根州弗林特市水中的铅。让我教你一些化学。这对于你试图弄清楚你真正深度投入的事情非常有用，对吧？所以我们在目前设计课程的方式中，有点本末倒置了。我们过多地考虑
what little learning nuggets get shoved in the cart and we forget to think about who's the horse pulling that cart? What does that horse need? That's, I think, the fundamental problem with the way we've designed our education system today. It's backwards. The building block skills follow the big, intriguing ideas and the curiosities. And then the kids need the building blocks skills, and they come back and say, please, teacher,
将什么样的小学习碎片塞进推车里，却忘了去思考拉车的马是谁。那匹马需要什么？我认为，这就是我们今天设计教育系统方式的根本问题。这是倒退的。基石技能跟随宏大、引人入胜的想法和好奇心而来。然后孩子们需要基石技能，他们会回来并说，求求你，老师，
I want to write a commentary about reforming the foster care system because I've lived through it and I've got some ideas. Can you remind me what does a good topic sentence really accomplish again? Because I need people to understand what I'm trying to say. It's important. Isn't it possible that there are some things that you have to learn that, in fact, cannot be connected to bigger concepts or more abstract concepts, that you actually just have to do the grunt work, if you will, of learning the nuts and bolts, the blocking and tackling? The nuts and bolts and the blocking and tackling are absolutely real, and they take grit and persistence and deep effort, right? But they follow a big idea. There is no nut and bolt and grunt work that doesn't have some reason for knowing it. When kids are asking, why do I need to do this? Why do I need to know this? That represents a failing of the design of the curriculum. It should be very clear to everybody in that room why you need to know this before you start learning it. They need to know it. They need to feel the need. And then, yes, you have to work hard. You have to have self-discipline. You have to have control. You have to have stick-toiveness. And all those things are things you develop within yourself. But we're fighting an uphill battle by trying to develop those skills when they're actually is no big reason why you should have to do these things that the kids are privy to.
我想写一篇关于改革寄养系统的评论，因为我亲身经历过并且有一些想法。你能提醒我一下一个好的主题句到底能实现什么吗？因为我需要人们理解我想表达的意思。这很重要。难道没有可能有些东西你必须学，事实上无法与更大的概念或更抽象的概念联系起来，你实际上只是必须做那些繁重的工作，如果你愿意的话，去学习那些基本功、基础的攻防阻截？基本功和基础的攻防阻截是绝对真实的，它们需要坚韧、毅力和深入的努力，对吧？但它们跟随着一个宏大的想法。没有任何基础和繁重的工作是没有了解它的某种理由的。当孩子们问，为什么我需要做这个？为什么我需要知道这个？这代表了课程设计的失败。在开始学习之前，房间里的每个人都应该非常清楚你为什么需要知道这个。他们需要知道它。他们需要感受到这种需求。然后，是的，你必须努力工作。你必须有自律。你必须有控制力。你必须有坚持不懈的精神。所有这些事情都是你在自己内心发展的东西。但当我们试图发展这些技能而实际上并没有一个宏大的理由让你应该去做这些孩子们能接触到的事情时，我们是在进行一场逆水行舟的战斗。
You also talk about something that effective teachers do, which is they expose young people to diverse perspectives in a way that is open-minded and experimental. And you saw this happening in a class you observed at a school in New York. Talk about what you saw and heard, Mary Helen. I think teachers can design their curricula in such a way that they invite young people into a new world of thinking in that disciplinary domain. So in one particular class I saw, which I thought was so skillfully done, this 10th grade history teacher in a school in New York called the class, democracy is an argument.
你还谈到了优秀教师所做的一件事，那就是以开放和实验的方式让年轻人接触不同的观点。你在纽约一所学校观摩的一节课上就看到了这一点。玛丽·海伦，请谈谈你所看到和听到的一切。我认为教师可以设计他们的课程，以某种方式引导年轻人进入该学科领域内的一种新的思维世界。因此，在我看到的一堂特别的课上，我觉得做得非常巧妙，那是纽约一所学校的一位十年级历史老师，这堂课的名字叫“民主是一个论点”。
And he taught American history from the perspective of the tension that's constantly present between the needs of individuals and the needs of groups. and they examined all of American history from this tension. And by looking from this perspective, what that teacher has brilliantly done is inherently set up kids to think about as they learn what happened and when and where and the implications of that,
他从个人需求与群体需求之间不断存在的紧张关系的视角来教授美国历史，他们从这种紧张关系出发审视了整个美国历史。通过从这个视角审视，这位老师出色地做到了这一点：在学生学习什么、何时何地以及其影响时，自然而然地引导他们去思考，
they're set up to look for a bigger hidden idea, which is what are the tensions behind the values and the beliefs of the various actors and how do they balance themselves and how does the tension between those lead to the unfolding of historical events. It helped the kids to think deeply about the history and also to inevitably see the lessons from history
他们被引导去寻找一个更深层的隐藏理念，即各种行为者背后的价值观和信念之间存在着什么样的张力，它们是如何自我平衡的，以及这些张力如何导致了历史事件的展开。这帮助孩子们深入思考历史，并不可避免地看到了历史中蕴含的教训，
that apply in our current world now. When we come back, flipping the classroom script. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedan. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. Mary Helen Imordino-Yang is a scholar at the University of Southern California. She feels that a good part of our education system is increasingly focused on the transmission of information. information. Especially in the age of AI, this would seem like a prescription to become redundant
这些教训适用于我们现在的世界。当我们回来时，颠覆课堂脚本。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦达姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦达姆。玛丽·海伦·伊莫迪诺-杨是南加州大学的一名学者。她认为我们的教育体系很大一部分越来越专注于信息的传输。特别是 在AI时代，这似乎成了迅速变得过时的药方
very quickly. Supercomputers have read more documents, more books, more scientific papers than any human. What are the skills that will prove indispensable and irreplaceable in the years to come? The ability to step back and see connections, to see how something that is true in one context might fail in another, to integrate knowledge and skills with judgment and ethics. All of this, of course, is what Mary Helen is talking about when she talks about transcendent thinking. I asked her how she has brought these ideas to bear in her own teaching. Yeah, in my own teaching, I mean, at this point in my life, I teach parents, I teach teachers, but I teach classes for graduate students, right?
超计算机已经阅读了比任何人类都多的文件、书籍和科学论文。在未来几年里，哪些技能将被证明是不可或缺和无可替代的？退一步并看到联系的能力，看到在一种情况下正确的东西如何在另一种情况下失败的能力，将知识和技能与判断力和道德相结合的能力。所有这一切，当然就是玛丽·海伦在谈论超越性思维时所谈论的内容。我问她是如何将这些想法带入她自己的教学中的。是的，在我自己的教学中，也就是说，在我人生的这个阶段，我教父母，我教老师，但我教的是研究生的课程，对吧？
What I do is I really try to engage people in their own meaning making. I put up the data, the story. It's like a journey. I think of the curriculum as a journey. come with me on a journey through a way of thinking about these things. I'm going to introduce you to a whole bunch of new evidence stories and stuff, and then we're going to think together about, okay, what does this mean now? Applying it back to your own practice, to your own understanding of the concepts.
我所做的是，我真的试图让人们参与到他们自己的意义建构中。我列出数据、故事。这就像是一段旅程。我认为课程就是一段旅程。和我一起踏上一段以某种方式思考这些事情的旅程。我将向你们介绍一大堆新的证据、故事和材料，然后我们将一起思考，好吧，这意味着什么？将其应用回你自己的实践中，应用回你对自己对这些概念的理解中。
So there's a famous neuroscientist, Dan Schachter, who did a very interesting experiment decades ago now, where he asked people a simple question, how many windows are in your living room? And the majority of people answer that question and you say, how did you answer that question? The majority of people answered that question by recounting that I had no idea the answer unless I just happened to have bought drapes last week, right? But what I did was I closed my eyes, imagined myself in my living room, and walked around and counted. and that's the way memory actually works when it's deep, meaningful, complex memory for the kinds of things we really want kids to accomplish in school. You live in the living room of that disciplinary space so experientially, richly, that you then can resituate yourself in that
所以有一位著名的神经科学家，丹·沙克特，他在几十年前做了一个非常有趣的实验，他问人们一个简单的问题，你的客厅里有多少扇窗户？大多数人回答了这个问题，你说，你是怎么回答这个问题的？大多数人回答这个问题时都会叙述说，我根本不知道答案，除非我上周刚好买过窗帘，对吧？但我的做法是，我闭上眼睛，想象自己坐在客厅里，四处走动并数了数。这就是记忆在面对我们真正希望孩子在学校里完成的那种深层的、有意义的、复杂的记忆时实际运作的方式。你如此亲身体验、丰富地生活在那个学科空间的客厅里，然后你才能在那个
disciplinary frame and walk around and count windows, so to speak. You can derive information that you never had memorized before. We forget in a education that the core memory system of the brain that holds together the memories we so care about, which are semantic memories, memories for facts and information, procedural memories, memories for how to do stuff. Those two kinds of memories are organized in the brain and mind by what you would call autobiographical memory. It's like the hat stand of memory that all the other stuff gets hung on. It's the experience of having been here thinking about these things, the personal, subjective, lived experience of engaging with this opportunity to learn
学科框架中重新定位自己，四处走动并数窗户，可以说。你可以推导出你以前从未背诵过的信息。我们在教育中忘记了，大脑中保持着我们如此关心的记忆的核心记忆系统——也就是语义记忆（对事实和信息的记忆）、程序记忆（关于如何做事的记忆）。这两种记忆在脑海中是由你所谓的自传体记忆组织起来的。它就像是记忆的衣帽架，所有其他东西都挂在上面。正是这种曾经在这里思考过这些事情的体验，即参与这个学习机会的个人、主观、生活体验，
that becomes the frame on which the information gets connected. When I teach, I try to bring people on a journey with me. And I don't make this a secret. I tell them, this is what I'm doing. I'm going to introduce you to interesting case studies, interesting findings, interesting pieces, of information, interesting videos of people that are embodying ideas that I want us to try to learn about. What do you see in this?
成为了信息得以连接的框架。当我教书时，我试图带人们和我一起踏上旅程。而且我并不保密。我告诉他们，这就是我在做的事情。我将向你介绍有趣的案例研究、有趣的发现、有趣的信息片段、体现了我希望我们尝试学习的思想的人的有趣视频。你在这其中看到了什么？
And I establish the students as agentic, curious learners. They are the people who show up in the space like scientists trying to figure out what's the idea here and how does it square with the things I've known before and what sense does it make. And that's the entry point into the curriculum rather than let me give you the basis. information about the brain. We're going to start with all the parts, and then we'll talk about what they do, and then next week we'll get into the important stuff about how it works. Let's just look at videotapes of people, kids, teachers, right? People learning, people out in the
我把学生确立为具有能动性的、好奇的学习者。他们是那些出现在这个空间里的人，就像科学家一样，试图弄清楚这里的理念是什么，它与我以前所知道的事物如何吻合，以及它有什么意义。这是进入课程的切入点，而不是让我给你提供关于大脑的基础信息。我们将从所有部分开始，然后我们将讨论它们的作用，然后下周我们将进入关于它是如何运作的重要内容。让我们来看看人、孩子、老师的录像带，对吧？人们在学习，人们在户外
world together, and watch what's happening, and then think backwards learning about, well, how is the brain and the body enabling those things to happen? And how are they looking different in these different contexts, and why? And what does this mean for how we might support learning in these different contexts. So we turn it backwards around and intrigue people with the examples first and then work backward once they have seen the example to help them think about, okay, let me tell you some of the facts about what's going on behind here now. How does that change your ability to analyze and understand what you could learn from this? I mean, it sounds almost self-evident when you put it this way, but really what you're saying
世界一起，观察正在发生的事情，然后倒推着学习，嗯，大脑和身体是如何使这些事情发生的？以及它们在这些不同的环境中是如何看起来不同的，为什么？这对我们如何在这些不同的环境中支持学习意味着什么。所以我们把它倒过来，先用例子吸引人们，然后一旦他们看到了例子，就倒推着工作，帮助他们思考，好吧，让我告诉你一些关于这里幕后发生的事情的事实。这如何改变你分析和理解你能从中学习到的东西的能力？我的意思是，当你这样说时，这听起来几乎是不言而喻的，但实际上你所说的是
is that education is actually not about the things that you're teaching. students, it's actually about the students themselves. If the students are at the heart of education, if the focus is on students, what they come to love, their own understanding of themselves, their place in the world, then all the learning and the facts and the information almost come along with that rather than starting with the facts and the learning. Yeah, this is an idea that we've been writing about and advocating for for some time. And I have a paper with several colleagues that's available on the internet called weaving a colorful cloth, which is about this notion. And what we're arguing is that we need to re-center education, like a Copernican shift. We're
教育实际上与你正在教学生的东西无关，它实际上与学生本人有关。如果学生是教育的核心，如果焦点在学生身上，他们在乎什么，他们对自己的理解，他们在世界上的地位，那么所有的学习、事实和信息几乎都随之而来，而不是从事实和学习开始。是的，这是我们一段时间以来一直在写文章和倡导的一个想法。我和几位同事在互联网上发表了一篇名为《编织一块五彩斑斓的布》的论文，就是关于这个概念的。我们的观点是，我们需要重新以教育为中心，就像一次哥白尼式的转向。我们正在
changing the perspective on the metrics and the processes that we have. So, you know, right now for so long what we've done is we're basically standing on the earth, making the earth the center and watching the kids and the learning outcomes go by. And when they go in the wrong direction or they slow down or things happen, we don't really know what to do about it, right? We can't make sense of that. But when we reframe so that we realize that, oh, another way to understand this, which is equally correct, but more useful, is that the experience of the person doing the thinking and learning, their subjective experiences the center of the solar system, and the rest of us and our learning outcomes are spinning around and watching that. All of a sudden,
改变我们现有的指标和过程的视角。所以，你知道，长期以来我们所做的一直是，我们基本上站在地球上，让地球成为中心，看着孩子和学习成果从身边掠过。当他们走错方向或者放慢速度或者发生事情时，我们真的不知道该怎么做，对吧？我们无法理解这一点。但是，当我们重新构建框架，意识到，哦，理解这一点的另一种方式——它是同样正确的，但更有用——是进行思考和学习的人的体验，他们的主观体验是太阳系的中心，而我们其他人以及我们的学习成果都在围绕着这一点旋转并观察它。突然之间，
the paradoxes, when we look up into the sky, many of them fall away because it now makes sense. from this new perspective, why they're moving in a direction that didn't conform to our previous expectations, right? And so when we refocus the educational enterprise on the subjective experience of thinking, what does it feel like to me to think here? How does thinking here change the way in which I engage with the process of learning? When we focus on that as the core of the enterprise, that's actionable. That helps us to make sense. sense of why the learning outcomes are as they are and how we might change them if we're not happy with them.
当我们抬头望向天空时，许多悖论都消失了，因为从这个新视角来看，它们为什么会朝着不符合我们先前预期的方向移动，现在变得有意义了，对吧？因此，当我们把教育事业重新聚焦于思考的主观体验时，在这里思考对我来说是什么感觉？在这里思考如何改变我参与学习过程的方式？当我们把这作为核心事业时，这是可操作的。这有助于我们理解为什么学习成果会是现在这样，以及如果我们对它们不满意，我们可能会如何改变它们。
In our education systems, we focus way too much on the learning outcome as the metric of the functioning of the system. And the problem with that is it doesn't tell you what you need to know. What kids don't meet the achievement marks you want, we don't know what to do about that. What we need to do in tandem is go back and really analyze how are kids thinking with a What does it mean to think here? What does it feel like to think here? What is my process when I'm tackling a problem? And as we start to uncover that, that's actionable. And that's what really skilled teachers hone in on. I understand that your own daughter had a very different experience of education when she attended a school in Denmark.
在我们的教育系统中，我们过分关注学习成果作为系统运作的指标。这样做的问题在于它不能告诉你你需要知道什么。当孩子们没有达到你想要的成绩标准时，我们不知道该怎么办。我们需要做的是同时回过头来真正分析孩子们是如何思考的。在这里思考意味着什么？在这里思考是什么感觉？当我解决问题时我的过程是什么？当我们开始揭示这一点时，这是可操作的。而这正是真正熟练的老师所关注的焦点。据我所了解，你自己的女儿在丹麦的一所学校上学时有着非常不同的教育体验。
Tell me the story of what happened. Yeah. So when our own daughter was in 10th grade, she had been in public school. She was doing very well. But she was also frustrated by the fact that she felt like her very rigorous academic curriculum and this high performing public school limited her ability to take intellectual risks. So I remember her expressing to me her frustration in AP biology when, you know, there was a question and she knew perfectly well what the answer was that she was supposed to answer on this AP biology test. But she wondered why it wasn't another explanation, and she wanted to put that so she could get feedback on why that couldn't be true also. But she knew that wasn't what they were looking for, and she knew you have to get an A on this class or you're not going to get to go to college. So she had to not ask, right? And she was angry about that. So we were looking for an opportunity for her to really grow herself in a different kind of school, just for a bit. In Denmark, they have schools called after schools, after school school.
给我讲讲发生的故事。好的。所以当我们的女儿上十年级时，她一直在公立学校上学。她表现得很好。但她也感到沮丧，因为她觉得她在这个高性能公立学校里非常严谨的学术课程限制了她承担智力风险的能力。所以我记得她向我表达了她在AP生物学课上的沮丧，当时，你知道，有一个问题，她完全知道她应该在这份AP生物学测试中回答的答案是什么。但她想知道为什么没有另一种解释，她想提出那个解释，以便就能得到反馈，为什么那个解释不可能也是真的。但她知道这不是他们要找的，而且她知道你必须在这门课上得A，否则你就无法上大学。所以她不得不不问，对吧？她对此感到生气。所以我们一直在寻找一个机会，让她在一种不同的学校里真正成长自己，哪怕只是一会儿。在丹麦，他们有被称为“后学校”（after-school school）的学校。
And what they are is a one-year opportunity in a kind of a folk school format to come together with youth from across the country who share interests with you. So kids from all walks of life from across Denmark who share an interest in orchestra music, go to one of these schools, in sports, in arts, right? These kids sort of find one of these community schools and they opt into an extra year of school in between their schools. a required school, which ends in ninth grade, which is a little older than our ninth grade, and then making a choice about what kind of adult trajectory they're going to take. Are they going to go on to more education or travel or do work or what? And so these kids all come together and the school that my daughter attended, she was the only foreign student. And so the school was about what they called social studies. It was about situating yourself as a Danish citizen
它们是什么呢？它们是一种为期一年的机会，以一种大众学校（folk school）的形式，将来自全国各地、与你有共同兴趣的年轻人聚集在一起。所以来自丹麦各地各行各业、对管弦乐音乐有共同兴趣的孩子去其中一所学校，对体育、艺术有共同兴趣的孩子也去，对吧？这些孩子们找到这些社区学校之一，并在他们的学校之间选择额外的一年的学校。规定学校在九年级结束，这比我们的九年级稍大一点，然后对他们将采取什么样的成人轨迹做出选择。他们是继续接受教育、旅行还是工作，或者什么？所以这些孩子们聚集在一起，我女儿去的学校，她是唯一的外国学生。所以这所学校是关于他们所谓的社会研究。它是关于将你自己定位为丹麦公民
in this historical context, and using math, science, outdoor activities, you know, service to the community, historical analysis, all these things, to try to really think about what do we want for our nation. My daughter attended this school the year after President Trump was elected the first time, and people in Europe were concerned about a Syrian refugee crisis. There were people pouring into the continent from terrible refugee situations. they were trying to absorb them in, but they also were having a crisis of identity themselves. How do we manage with all these new citizens who, you know, don't garden and eat like us, right?
在这个历史背景下，并利用数学、科学、户外活动、对社区的服务、历史分析，所有这些东西，来真正思考我们对我们的国家有什么期望。我女儿上这所学校是在特朗普总统第一次当选的第二年，欧洲的人们对叙利亚难民危机感到担忧。有源源不断的人从可怕的难民处境中涌入这块大陆。他们正试图将他们融入其中，但他们自己也经历着认同危机。我们如何应对所有这些新公民，你知道的，他们不进行园艺，吃的也不像我们，对吧？
And so the school, rather than just teaching about that, they situated the kids in the history of this. And then they put all the kids, 140 kids and the teachers, onto buses and drove them 17 hours to crack out Poland, where they spent a week studying Auschwitz and the role of the Danish people in the Holocaust. And they then helped the kids think about learning from that history. How do you want to make sense of and manage the refugee crisis in Europe today? Because it's your issue to manage 17-year-olds. This is your world. You're soon going to be taking over the country and running things.
所以这所学校，与其只是教授这些，不如把孩子们置于这段历史中。然后他们把所有的孩子，140个孩子和老师，都送上大巴车，开了17个小时来到波兰克拉科夫，在那里花了一周时间研究奥斯威辛集中营以及丹麦人民在大屠杀中的角色。然后他们帮助孩子们从这段历史中吸取教训。你想如何理解和管理当今欧洲的难民危机？因为这是你们17岁年轻人需要管理的问题。这是你们的世界。你们很快就要接管国家并管理事情了。
How do you want to position yourselves to be able to manage this crisis? And it was an incredible opportunity where they let the kids with support, with historical knowledge, with adults thinking with them, really start to grapple with the real big, fraught issues that were facing their country and their society and their world now. What was your daughter's impression of the school compared to what she was used to back home? Did she feel like it was a more authentic experience of what education was supposed to be like? I think it was actually surprisingly difficult for her. She expressed, she loved the school. She never said she didn't enjoy herself. But it was extremely difficult for her to be in an environment where there were not assignments and metrics and rubrics and somebody telling her what grade she got.
你们想如何定位自己以便能够管理这场危机？这是一个绝佳的机会，他们让孩子们在支持下、在历史知识下、与成年人一起思考，真正开始努力应对摆在他们国家、社会和世界面前的那些真正重大、棘手的问题。与她在家乡习惯的相比，你女儿对这所学校的印象是什么？她是否觉得这是一次更真实的、教育本应如此的体验？我认为对她来说实际上出乎意料地困难。她表示，她喜欢这所学校。她从没说过她不开心。但对她来说，身处一个没有作业、指标、评分标准（rubric）且没有人告诉她得了什么成绩的环境中，是极其困难的，
And she was embarrassed to admit, she told me, that it was very difficult for her to just work in this. open-ended way. She was so used to being a good student. And what that means is teachers give you really hard stuff and you deliver on it, right? These teachers were inviting the kids into the physics lab organizing a curriculum around concepts and saying, what would you like to do? Dig in, right? And we're here to answer your questions to support you. I don't know. Are you done with this physics problem and project or do you want to work more on it? What have you accomplished? Where are you stuck? What have you learned? What would you do differently next time? And they refuse to give direct feedback about the end point, the achievement, and she found it incredibly difficult.
她不好意思地承认，她告诉我，仅仅以这种开放式的方式工作对她是极其困难的。她太习惯于当一个好学生了。这意味着老师给你非常难的东西，而你完成了它，对吧？这些老师邀请孩子们进入物理实验室，围绕概念组织课程，并说，你想做什么？深入研究吧，对吧？我们在这里回答你的问题以支持你。我不知道。你完成这个物理问题和项目了吗，还是你想再多做一点？你完成了什么？你卡在哪里了？你学到了什么？下次你会做哪些不同的事情？他们拒绝提供关于终点、成就的直接反馈，她觉得这不可思议地困难。
And at one point, about halfway through the year, she would talk to me every night before she went to bed, and she said to me, you know, mom, I've realized something about myself. It's kind of embarrassing to admit. I said, yeah. She said, yeah, you know, you know those kids in high school who have a boyfriend or a girlfriend, not because they really love the person, but because they just, you know, want somebody to walk into the party with and to sit with that lunch and to laugh at their jokes and tell me. they look nice? And I said, yeah. And she said, well, that's grades for me.
在某个时刻，大约在一学年过半的时候，她每天晚上睡觉前都会跟我聊天，她对我说，妈妈，我意识到关于我自己的事。这有点不好意思承认。我说，什么。她说，对吧，你知道，你知道高中里那些有男朋友或女朋友的孩子，不是因为他们真的很爱这个人，而是因为他们只是，你知道，想要一个可以一起走进派对、一起坐着吃午餐、对他们的笑话大笑并告诉他们
I'm ashamed to admit that I use them to remind myself that I'm smart, that I have potential, that I've worked hard, rather than thinking about how do I decide for myself if I'm smarter I have potential I've worked hard. Why am I doing this? And she had to really rethink and re-engage in a very different way in her own work. And it was extremely difficult, but so fulfilling for her over time. And I think it really fundamentally changed the way she oriented herself towards school and the learning process. She's now about to start a PhD. You know, I think she really re-engaged with the opportunity school provided to learn for her own learning rather than for the metrics and achievement goals that other people set for her.
他们看起来不错的人？我说，是的。她说，好吧，对我来说成绩就是这样。我很不好意思地承认，我用它们来提醒自己我很聪明，我有潜力，我努力工作了，而不是去思考我该如何为自己决定我是否更聪明、我有潜力、我努力工作了。我为什么要这样做？她不得不重新思考，并以一种非常不同的方式重新投入到自己的工作中。这极其困难，但随着时间的推移，对她来说是如此充实。我认为这从根本上改变了她对学校和学习过程的定向方式。她现在即将开始攻读博士学位。你知道，我认为她真正重新投入到了学校提供的机会中，为了她自己的学习而学习，而不是为了别人为她设定的指标和成就目标。
And what she taught me, which was really eye-opening, is really difficult. The real struggle academically in education happens when the teachers step back. And you're not taking five APs with somebody else coming in and telling you, this is due on this day, and this is due on this day, and this is what an A is and this is what a C is,
而她教给我的、真正大开眼界的事情是，这真的很困难。教育中真正的学术挣扎发生在老师退后的时候。而你没有修五门AP课程，没有其他人进来告诉你，这个在这一天截止，那个在这一天截止，这就是A，这就是C，
and here's the rubric. When the teachers instead set out the opportunity and the kids need to decide for themselves what they're studying and why and how and whether they're done and what they've learned and what other people are learning and get feedback on that. That is where the hard work actually is. And what she told me is that without grades, without these formalized assignments and due dates, it was the hardest academic learning she's ever done. And it was fundamental to the way in which she now understands her own role in the scholarly world. Mary Helen Imordino-Yang is a psychologist and neuroscientist at the University of Southern California. She is the author of Emotions, Learning, and the Brain, exploring the educational implications of affective neuroscience.
这就是评分标准。相反，当老师设定了机会，孩子们需要自己决定他们在学习什么、为什么学、如何学、是否完成了、他们学到了什么、其他人正在学习什么，并获得对此的反馈时。这才是真正艰难的工作所在。她告诉我的是，没有成绩，没有这些形式化的作业和截止日期，这是她做过的最艰难的学术学习。这对于她现在理解自己学术世界中角色的方式是至关重要的。玛丽·海伦·伊莫迪诺-杨是南加州大学的心理学家和神经科学家。她是《情感、学习与大脑》的作者，该书探讨了情感神经科学的教育启示。
Mary Helen, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. It's a true pleasure. Do you have follow-up questions about learning for Mary Helen Imordino-Yang? Maybe you're a teacher who has discovered your own techniques for engaging students or a student with thoughts on how you think learning should unfold. If you'd be willing to share your question or comment with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Two or three minutes is plenty, and use the subject line, Learning.
玛丽·海伦，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。这真是我的荣幸。你对玛丽·海伦·伊莫迪诺-杨关于学习的问题有后续疑问吗？也许你是一位发现了自己吸引学生技巧的老师，或者是一位对学习应该如何展开有想法的学生。如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享你的问题或评论，请在手机上录制语音备忘录，并通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。两三分钟就足够了，并使用主题行：学习（Learning）。
That email address again is Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you love Hidden Brain and the ideas we explore on our show, please consider subscribing to our newsletter. Every week, we'll bring you new and interesting research
再次说明该电子邮件地址是：Ideas@hiddenbrain.org。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·帕尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·克雷尔、赖安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德里克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》以及我们在节目中探讨的想法，请考虑订阅我们的通讯。每周，我们都会为你带来关于人意味着什么的
about what it means to be human. You can check it out and subscribe at news.hiddenbrain.org. That's N-E-W-S dot hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. I'm going to be able to be. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
新的有趣研究。你可以在 news.hiddenbrain.org 查看并订阅。也就是 N-E-W-S 点 hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦达姆。再见。我将能够成为。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。